uh good morning everyone hope everyone
is having a great day
um i guess it's evening for the majority
of you
but
bright and early for me
so
today uh we're actually getting into our
um
so if everyone can see my screen it's
actually more complex than this
we're going to have you guys install r
we're going to kind of talk about the
structure how things operate go through
some conditional statements go through
loops um go through a break uh on this
uh on how to run an r script or that
script
and then we'll actually start getting
into uh a little bit more of that in
regards to vector scalars things like
that
uh
and this yeah so this doesn't include
everything we're going to cover because
i'm going to go into a little more depth
um as you can see we have three sets of
slides but we don't have to go through
all of them today but we'll go through
the majority of those
so the biggest piece that we're going to
first do because the way that i want
this to operate is you guys be able to
fall along in
tandem
is that we're going to install
r and r studio
so um
you know this is where we ended
yesterday that r is available on windows
mac and linux
and there's uh essentially binaries for
windows and mac for linux there can be
different things so if you want to
compile it yourself your morton able or
r studio do have those distribution
types so you could uninstall through the
package management
so what we're going to do
and i believe i posted these links
um yesterday as well but i'll post these
in here oh actually i think they can't
copy and paste this yeah okay let's type
it in
um so the first one you need to install
is
cram.rtproject.org
and then
[Music]
the other is
an r studio link
box or studio
download
okay
um and
so we go into this uh you can also
google as well um
crayon r
and there's the comprehensive r archive
network
um
generally speaking one of these six
should have what you need
for downloading but
if you don't see what you need right
there
we'll click this comprehensive r archive
network
and they should show up right here as
well so if you have linux mac or windows
go ahead and click on your distribution
so this computer is using windows 10
i'd go to download r for windows
and you can just download the base you
don't need these other contribution type
packages
and then it'll say right here this
download r
3.3.2 for windows
it's nice now are actually our comes in
32 and 64-bit versions
now it automatically includes both those
versions which is nice
so
the
thing is if you use um if for some
reason you didn't use rstudio and you're
just using base r
there are two types of base r in there
and this may be too small for everyone
to see
but if i go into r there's this ri386
and r x64
so the i386 version and it'll be a
little bit different for mac and linux
but um that version is for 32-bit which
means it'll only use a maximum of 4
gigabytes of ram
the arts x64 doesn't have those
limitations i think limitation 64
gigabytes um which nobody should have
and uh and so there's a lot more
processing power in that x64
so if you go to download
um it'll download it's about 70 megabit
file i'm not sure how long that'll take
for everyone um i'm going to
try to just hang out for a bit uh make
sure everyone gets that installed and um
if you guys are trying to download that
we'll also go to our studio you can
google that if you want as well
rsd is the first one on there there
should be a download rstudio link as
well you can click that it leads to the
same link that i posted in chat
and then from there depending on what os
version you have whether you have
windows vista 7 8 or 10
uh if you have mac if you have
one of these popular distributions like
ubuntu debian or fedora and red hat then
you can click one of those otherwise the
source code is probably through this
tarball and uh and then you could
compile it yourself
so what let's see we have
in my notes yesterday
we have 16 students so
what i'm going to give you guys do is
take a little bit of time
and and once you've installed
r and are able to open it and then also
installed our studio enable to open it
uh please let me know via chat and i'm
gonna make tick marks next to your guys
names to make sure that everybody has r
r studio before moving forward because i
don't want anyone to fall behind
if you have any questions in the
meantime just post it in chat i will
just be sitting here
until we get everyone
having r and r studio installed
okay
who should you have both those installed
okay perfect
um
okay
let's see
both our student console will be in
different pages
yeah um so the the r itself you have to
download first and that's because it
contains all the base functions and
whatnot uh and our studio is just an ide
it's a gui that sits on top of r you
don't have to having to open both those
um every time you want to run analyses
you just open r studio but you need r in
there to be able to process it so the
first one comes r comes from that crayon
that r dash project and then um our
studio comes from the other link the
products are studio download
okay
rahul got on our studio running
our studio great
um
chiefs to run
we've got both in stone
um
and that's the
crayon r
menish
um
the other one didn't hyperlink
so
okay
um
that
okay
uh yeah var prasad um yes install both
those
please just come on guys let's see where
you on the sheet
okay
[Music]
um
let's see
can we have both studio and console on a
single page
um oops that was supposed to get
everybody
okay
um
[Music]
okay
uh it's a teen were you here yesterday
first video
um so
uh what do you mean by studio and
console on the same page
did you install r first in our studio
and then opened our studio
i closed both of them down and reopen
it might just be that it has
had a few keys with the registry
because r should do that but our studio
shouldn't um
and just an fyi r can be a pain to try
to search for on your desktop
um
yeah if you have this instead of our
studio open i could see that happening
um
okay so who's here
okay
isaiah krishnan uh
have you had success with either of
those yet
[Music]
okay okay
i appreciate it
um in our studio
[Music]
let's see
manish not sure where you're at yet
let's see if we need this done
um
what does it cost down
good
oh no they don't reflect um
so i could
in r i could write x
um is assigned to three and then type x
here and it's three
and then r studio i could assign the
variable x to five and uh
if i ran that and then try to print x it
would be five so they're completely
independent um they're running different
environments
so you won't need our um i just wanna
make sure it opens for you and you could
do something like x
arrow assignment 3 and that works that
way we know that all the functionality
is working within r
before moving on
um
not able to see it at all or it's too
small
um okay let me stop sharing i'm not sure
why
try this again
okay is that any better for everyone
[Music]
working on our studio it's great
okay uh what do you need help with
[Music]
good
uh cervani how are you doing
then
i believe
is good yep
which is good
that's two wishes now um
uh yes they are independent
i'm good thank you for asking
no so um a a gui an ide is something
that rests on top
of it so it's like a visualization of
the actual mechanics of a program so if
you think of r like
you know um
something that can run only run c plus
or c sharp or something like that
versus uh you know having notepad or
eclipse ide or any of those other ones
that can handle processing various
languages
that's essentially what rstudio does it
only works for our language but
uh so the r is the base that contains
all the functionality we need and the r
studio just makes things a lot easier to
work with
um okay
so if we go to that link
um yeah manisha it should be uh it
should automatically identify your os so
you should be good there
um
sorry guys trying to get through
everyone on here um
on our studio
okay
um
[Music]
okay
looks like we have a couple new faces
that's great
um
okay so we have
and then
okay
let's see
[Music]
okay voila
okay
you see you
okay cancel done j done okay he's good
let's see
i'm good sir bonnie thanks for asking
um no you'll end up uh
you'll end up generally i mean you can
even uh
you know technically speaking
you could work from the command line
interface um for r
but you kind of just choose there i mean
there are other um
ides for r like if i googled it um
so python's famous for having a lot of
ides i know rodeo is one of them as well
um
eclipse can do it
so if you worked with either of those
we'll look at core of post
apparently there's other ones as well
like red r rattle blah blah so all these
do
the same thing that our studio does but
in different ways um
it may have different functionality from
our studio but all of them run on base r
you just generally don't have to open
base r because it's not as useful
um
yeah yeah um
get that out of the way
so yeah you'll want to choose one of
these first installers unless
you decide not to
work directly from the installer um you
can do a zip tarball or compile your own
source file but yeah this is the easiest
is just clicking whichever os you have
here
which is good for practice studio
console
uh we can't install it without r uh we
need both for it to work um you can
you can have r without rstudio which you
can't have the other way around
okay laura's both great
um
okay um hopefully y'all can hear me now
i'm not sure
why webex having a couple issues
uh yeah 3.3.2 that version's fine um
there's not too many differences between
these uh i mean mine might not even
be there um i can check though let's see
my art studio yeah it's a couple
versions behind and my r version
3.2.1 so yeah you know mine are slightly
further behind
but it tends to not be an issue because
but yeah that's the best version to get
okay so are we missing anyone um
okay um
um it doesn't have a
at least it hasn't in the past had some
sort of auto compiler for updating um r
doesn't
so um you can update packages but r
itself you have to go back to the the
crayon page to download on the newest
version
so as you can see you know mine's 3.2.1
for this r
um
and so i can end up doing the same thing
our studio
the same you can
update your packages
and you can check for updates in the
help file
so like it says rcd 1.0.44 is available
um and i could download it but i won't
do that for this course or not right now
oh um
yeah i mean art doesn't uh host like
a repository like get might in regards
to source code so um
and you know you can always if you use
git or subversion or something like that
you can always google get with r
and um there's packages for it
there's dev tools package and you can um
essentially do your
assignments to
um
load honor studio i'm not going to walk
everyone through this because uh it
requires a lot of work
on the initial front so generally
speaking
wherever you
wherever your
environment is saved is where the source
files will save so if i go to save this
the
r file went to save in my documents
and i could name this test1
and it's saved there
so then if i actually went into oops
if i went to my documents folder
i could find it
and we have this test one here if i
wanted to i could open with notepad and
there it is right there
yep
um i always just go through that quick
since it's not part of the
curriculum itself
but yes definitely can
is everybody good to move on
okay
if anyone's not just please say
something
otherwise move forward here
so if you are
uh we'll get into the repository in the
library
um
desktop shortcuts
uh yeah i mean if you have windows you
know the
you can always just if you didn't save
it
at onset you know you can always right
click
and um there used to be a way
well you can at least pin it to the
taskbar um there should be a way to just
you should be able to just drag and drop
it to your desktop and it will create a
shortcut
i don't see a desktop shortcuts
okay
did i answer everybody's questions
okay i hope so uh we'll move on if you
have any questions please feel free
so
we have this installed close chat for a
couple
um minutes
know it's always recommended to update
the most recent version but it's not
going to kill you and you know packages
um packages are externally created
sometimes by you know our studio but a
lot of times it's just created by the
community itself and they have to go
through a validation process with every
r in our studio update to make sure they
don't break
um
and and so you know
sometimes it's uh
slightly better to be maybe one or two
small versions behind
but
generally speaking you don't want to get
far behind because they tend to not have
legacy support so if you have a version
from a year or two ago a lot of packages
might not be supported so you want to
make sure
generally speaking that you have the
most recent version of the install
again because it doesn't automatically
check for you you'll have to go in and
do that
okay so we've installed this exe file
you know um everything in there all the
defaults
our console you should see that rx64 um
as long as you have four or more
gigabytes of ram it should have
installed both versions you can open it
you could type the number 3 or 10 or
whatever and hit enter and it should
show that as the next line it's
basically an automatic print function
if all that worked for you
then we have our studio and so it's a
gui it's an ide to help make things
easier for you and to help you be more
productive in the course
so in regards to it you know it's not a
requirement um
i won't be able to support some other
ide through the course if you have an
issue
since we're only leveraging our studio
but
you know if you prefer
eclipse or side views jgr or whatever
you can have any of these in as well
the desktop version is the most common
for rstudio
i haven't really worked with the web
browser version yet it's a little bit
newer but there is that capability as
well
regards to our studio um this is what
we'll spend our time in a decent chunk
of today and throughout this course
so again just as we talked about
yesterday
um we have four different panels and so
we have the source panel which is
basically kind of like a
notepad script
it'll highlight things and automatically
format things for you which is really
nice
and nothing in that runs nothing in that
that gets deleted without your say so
which is really nice
the council is basically the command
line or terminal so anything you do
there is basically only in memory as
soon as you close that it's gone so if
you you know want to quick test
something to make sure it works you can
run it there but ideally anything that
you're working in will be in the source
panel
the environment will show you what data
sets what variables etc you have in here
so something seems to be not working
that's one of those places that you
might want to check so if you create a
variable x and assigns it
some vector of numbers
and then you try to run the vector and
it won't produce any results you might
want to go to this global environment
and ensure that the variable x is still
in here
and then again this last piece there's
five tabs on here i can go through it on
my version as well
so on this r gui
this full size
five types of things there's
the file system itself so you can
leverage this i generally tend not to
any of your visualizations will show up
in here plots there's left and right
arrows so you'll be able to circle
through them you can zoom in
you can export as images or pdfs
and
cool
then we have the packages so
basically any external
functions any external packages are
generally 99 of the time hosted on the
crayon repository
um
r has built r r studio have built-in
functionality in regards to the
repository there's two ways to access
something um one may be that i want to
that's the search for if you have it
so one is through this install link
and you see it accesses the cran
repository right here
it'll go to install to wherever my
default library is and that's where it
hosts those packages
it'll install the dependencies that are
associated with it so there might be
other packages
or other functions in other packages
that are needed to run what you're doing
so if i wanted to install a random
forest package it's right there and i
can click install
and then you can see it installs here
the other way is that install that
packages
random forest and then i could run this
line of code both those will end up
producing
random forest on this list here
and then if you want to load it
and we're all going to do this in a
couple minutes
you can do library
reinforced these are case sensitive
and run this line um or you could just
check this box and that'll also load the
library
um
basically it's better to work from here
and that's because you know saying had
11 packages you need to load at startup
every time you don't want to come in
here and go hand check every package you
just want to be able to run a line of
code and have all of them load
the help file is a really cool feature
we're going to go into this in a few
minutes as well
basically our documentation all of it is
online but
it's built into our studio so you can
access a lot of that documentation
and then viewer isn't used too much
okay
questions
no packages right now but i will let you
know if there's specific packages you
need to
load
in regards to repositories basically
everything hosted on crayons so you
don't have to go to 20 different sources
to find a potential package that you
might need
you just need to use the crane
repository via one of these mechanisms
that i showed you
the two shortcuts you want to use the r
studio one so it should look like this
the background will probably be white
instead of black
but
um that's what you want to focus on so
um once you've installed r you don't
ever have to open it again um you just
need to open rstudio
use of library so library loads of
package um you know we could have just
called it package.load but
they named the function library so all
this does here i run that
library um
and you might get a warning message it
was built under version 3.3.2 so if you
have an old version like mine slightly
is um there could be potential bug
issues and that's why you want to stay
up to date but now the random force
package is loaded if i go over here you
can see it's checked as well so now
whatever functions are in random forest
and you can click through now like get
tree function
would actually work if i
you know
produce some new
attribute versus
if i had done this before i'd go to the
library the function wouldn't work
supposed to want to use a function how
can i know which package has that
function
um
google's your best bet and generally
you'll know the package and uh
um and not the reverse you might not
necessarily know that combine is what
you need to use
but um
yeah so
if we went okay so get tree is a
function in here we'll see if the help
function works
for external packages so we're going to
do this help search as well but get
three was the function we saw
if we run that
yeah it shows it here and then it shows
that the package name is random forest
um so you can go about it that way
so google is one way um you can search
for get tree and r and it should tell
you random course package um or you can
directly type the question mark in front
of the function and it'll let you know
what package it's a part of
so a package is the source file
and
and so
that's essentially the installer just
like you installed r r studio and when
you double clicked our studio that's
basically your library
so library is just accessing those
packages so you can basically imagine
that a package is a zip file
and and so you can't use what's in it
yet um on the install that package but
on library that's essentially unzipping
and loading those files
okay uh get your you don't need to worry
about i was just giving an example
but uh it's to show this health
functionality and we're going to kind of
go through all of this as well to let
you guys play around a bit as we work
through this
um so don't worry about the get tree
itself um this was all just an example
to show you how it operates
okay
so
a couple things to know um
not critically important now but
sometimes you might want to tweak these
in the future um i rarely ever have
so our starts in the working directory
also called the workspace
i'll show you how to get that working
directory and set a different one
if present
basically anything you have you can
attach
so instead of for example the installed
packages and
loading a bunch of packages and
libraries
you can actually
it's a little bit quirky but you can
actually append
libraries that are loaded directly to
your r profile so anytime you load it
those things will already be
automatically loaded you wouldn't have
to
re-run the install.package and library
functions
you could just open r and it basically
becomes part of the base package
and our data generally when you save our
studio files it will allow you to save
in our data file which is kind of like a
snapshot of what you've run and
everything else
okay um so everything are basically
user-defined objects uh we
are worries a little less about global
and local type environments so don't
really get uh too honed in or worried
about that
um
the only thing that tends to matter is
that there are
overrides so if i assign the number five
to x
well
somebody can
i'd love to see what you guys think
would happen
so if i ran these two lines of code
then i went to print x you'd have to
type print just showing you um
what would x show as
okay so yeah if we just ran x at five um
print x we have x equals five
but if we ran everything uh yep um x
equals three just like you guys said
and uh and the reason for that is
because it's uh it overwrites the
assignment so you need to make sure that
you label things in a meaningful way
and that way you don't accidentally
overwrite operators
the one thing you also can't do in r
which is a good thing for the most part
is that you can't assign you know
some sort of string or numbers or
anything to a function that already
exists so
i couldn't call a function um library
you better not let me um
and try to run library equals five
if it lets me
that's quirky
let's
see okay
or it might um
so essentially generally speaking um
it'll either not let you do this or
it'll really screw some things up later
when you have things that are labeled
the same as functions so please please
please don't ever do what i just did
um
and so yeah here's the point that you
can see in the global environment
i have three things in here we have
something called color equals green
uh something called library equals five
and something called x equals three
you can actually clear objects from the
workspace in this way there's also going
to be another way
that is syntax driven
okay
so
let's have everyone do this you don't
have to um actually
tell me
what your working directory is
but
you want to type get wd
open and close paren and it should
automatically always include the close
pairing close quotations close anything
you need
in our studio that's one nice feature
but go ahead and run the get wd
open and close parentheses to return
your working directory and just make let
me know if that
works for you
okay good that's at least five yeses
um i feel comfortable moving forward so
if i did the same thing
get working directory
it'll show me that that file path is in
matte documents
well
let's say i wanted to change that
working directory
you know i have all my
excel or csv files
in my downloads folder right
so
let's print documents downloads
okay
i'm going to try to file pass it
um
all right
windows 10 doesn't file path anymore um
so one and one of the weird things if
you are
um
with r if you're working in windows is
you'll see these forward and back
slashes so what i was trying to show you
with this downloads path i guess i could
go into something else in here
um
okay yeah so dallas doesn't really show
the path
so if i type this here you can see um
i think this is only applies to windows
i don't think it's for mac and linux but
you'll see these flashes going in this
direction but as you can see when we ran
get working directory their forward
slash is not backslashes so
if you have this um you can
you're more than welcome to copy and
paste that in but you're going to have
to change all these flashes
to forward slashes to make that your
working directory
okay so the working directory is
essentially
where you're accessing files
and you can have multiple working
directories uh i generally don't
recommend that as well
uh and so you want a folder system that
is easy to access for that
um
oh yeah i don't know
internal
so we can do that real quick and see
i haven't seen that error before
[Music]
ah perfect
oh that was the actual syntax you said
okay
i thought that was your output
yeah especially if you're on you want
get wd but then open and close
paren
does it clean up automatically once we
close the session uh it depends
so if
if i go to close our studio right now
it will say the following files have un
saved changes
so do you want to save the following
so test1.r is what i labeled this which
is just essentially a text window you
know the source code
so i can choose to save that and the
revisions there
and then you have our data as well which
would save
what's in the global environment any
plots that you made anything that's in
the console um anything that's here
so if you didn't want to do that you
could uncheck this so it wouldn't save
the working environment or the console
it would just save what's in this test
file and then if you uncheck that it
would just wouldn't save anything
okay perfect and yeah i mean i i
definitely uh
you know if you guys are asking
questions and able to help answer each
other throughout this um that's
fantastic because it means you're able
to read code and assess it which is an
important feature
so um and and it'll help the class go
smoother as well um so yeah please feel
free to help one another throughout this
um
the our data is the snapshot the working
directory is where you would save
something like your csv files
so we'll
it'll actually happen next week that we
start loading csv files
but
so they are different though
okay um so there is one other way uh so
that's the way i recommend the setting
the working directory because then um
you know it and you have it saved right
up here
but the other
should be in tools global options
and uh
and so here you can see
that i actually had
if you aren't in a project then you
don't define it then my working
directory is user's mat downloads uh
coursera r because i
extracted it i ran a script to extract
some stuff from coursera
this tells you your r version you can
choose to
have other functionalities in here as
well like restore previously uh open
source documents and start up restore
the r data
ask or always or never save the
workspace to our data on
exit um do you want them to save the
history do you want there to be
debugging um yeah generally
traceback and eric's inspector this can
be useful um if you keep getting error
issues we don't get too much into
debugging and
i'm not a
superstar at debugging either
so it's not necessarily a requirement
but it can be useful because the
tracebacks will let you go through
different sequences of functions
and you know like i will go through all
of these as well
or i'll just go through briefly but some
things like this general code and
editing a lot of this automatically
handles um formatting for you so you
don't want to change too much in here
you can um
have things that show up like white
space characters indent guides blah blah
blah if that helps you
let's see we don't need to worry about
that
uh
you can do diagnosticking
okay
if you want to change the appearance um
you can see that i have it looks like
idle finger set but you can
choose any you know color combination
combo that you want
as well as font size uh font et cetera
you can choose what is in each pane
so if in this environment history you
want to add some other tabs
so you want the plots to be there
instead um you're more than welcome
uh so you can essentially restructure
this any way that you want
the packages that package pane that's
what you guys see here
secure download generally good
the rest is fine
s-weave i don't use
latex you might use but probably not
if you do want to create a spelling
dictionary you can
there's also so yeah if you want to
connect a git account or sbn you can do
that here
and uh that if you google like get an r
that'll lead to that first link which is
a full walkthrough
and then if you do publish
rstudio or swirl something like that
that's an option as well
okay
so let's actually go back in here
so
what are we going to do um
let's see so let's use
ggplot2 um i'm gonna
try to make this bigger so you guys can
see both things at the same time right
so i kind of want you guys to take
let's take like maybe two minutes for
this slide
you can see there are six different
functionalities here
and so ggplot2 is a
library
it's a graphing library it's really good
and so i kind of want you to play around
with it for a second right so the
the help that start doesn't require
anything and that'll
we choose and you can click the number
as well to highlight the line
it should be
it'll be different depending on what you
have but if you have windows it's ctrl
enter to run that line
and
if you see down here um i know it's
smaller
this actually leads directly to the data
analysis are manuals so all of them are
manuals
you can use that
sometimes it's easier for that piece
just to do it in
google
but if we want to do help that package
right
well let's see our package name is
ggplot2
and you know if you guys can type all
this in to make sure it's working for
you that you feel comfortable and
understand it that would be really
beneficial
so if i ctrl enter help gd plot two
oops
and see if it needs
that
once i have to install the
package let's see
okay
let's try to run
interesting
no documentation okay
um that's interesting since hadley
wickham developed youtube.com
let's see if we try to double question
marks like they suggested
okay
so it looks like
ggplot2 has been yet attached
multiple help pages you can see these
are all the package names with carrot
and then some sort of functionality that
uses gdp plot two
here's the package is actually ggplot2
there's auto plot access secondary gdpr
blah blah blah
the yeah the single and the double
question mark ends up being really
really useful
um
in regards to being able to quickly look
at packages um ggplot2 is weird since
it's an external package um so if we
tried this let's see if we can try this
with
[Music]
carrot
all right that's not going to work for
any external packages
i will make a note of that all right so
what i would suggest then is the um
question mark in front
where it's double question marks for
packages and single question marks for
functions
so you can do that
and then let's see anything else there's
a keyword searches as well so if you
want to find things that say like random
forest you can do help.search
with random forest in there
this question mark help
will end up
working for
most anything um
so it'll give you actually so just like
a package would
it'll give you the function itself
you can choose the topic and then
there's all of these different
parameters or filters you can include as
well
it'll end up telling you okay well you
can have these functions within package
this is what libloc does it looks at
character vectors of directory names and
r libraries
you can be verbose so that could be true
or false if the filename is reported etc
and then there's a lot of base packet as
well so like the if you wanted to just
find out about um
say we wanted to the base
functionalities in here
in r we want to know
how mean works here
well
we could do that question mark mean and
it'll show us that mean is in the base
package
it works here that mean you can choose
the vector
or matrix or whatever you're trying to
calculate the mean of
you can see that trim is the fraction of
observations to be trimmed from each end
of x before the means computed
generally from a statistical standpoint
we don't do that but if you did have
really strong outliers um that's why
trim could be used
n-a-r-m is uh uh do you decide to remove
missing values before calculating and so
there's a lot of functionality there
it's generally using this or searching
within
the repository itself
okay and then we've kind of gone through
this work as well before right
um
so
the way that we handle libraries and
packages
so
um
yeah this is list available packages to
load
again that number sign operator
essentially shows us that um
we can comment that out
and then if we wanted to do this library
i'll probably have more than you all on
this can run that and it'll show the
packages in my layer libraries matte
documents are windows library 3.3
so all these are the packages that i
have
and then
the packages in library program files
are 3.3.1 library these are the base
packages that are part of our itself
so these are the ones that i have like
installed at some point on top of that
if you want to load a package so say i
want to load
um
[Music]
so let's have everyone do this uh
we'll do party
that's easy to type right
so first we want to do install about
packages
actually i should do it up here
um
[Music]
install that packages so plural
and then we need to put that inside of
quotations
and then it'll close those quotations
it'll close that parentheses for us you
can highlight that run that
it'll say that it's installing those you
get a zip file it'll check that for the
sums and then it'll download that binary
um
okay so that's installed great right
well now if we want to load that library
so we can access the functionality
within it
we want to do library and then
parentheses party so we go ahead and run
that
it looks like it's loading these other
required packages party won't operate
necessarily well without it
and
i'll get this warning message you
shouldn't that r was built under our
version 3.3.2 so after this course i'll
obviously um need to upgrade today
and um
let's see that's primarily what you'll
use if you want to look at the contents
within the library itself you can do
library help
and then the party package
and if we go ahead and run this
it's basically a lot from the crane
repository right so all these are an
easier more accessible way to get there
it tells you what it is it's a
computational toolbox for recursive
partitioning um the core of the package
is seed tree
which is conditional inference trees
blah blah blah blah right um you don't
have to know what the heck all this
means
and uh and then you have these
dependencies here that means it uses
some functions of these other packages
to work
so it might also import some other
functions which is perfectly fine
you don't have to really worry about
that and then you have the actual
functions here what they do
so if you're running a random forest
versus a binary tree
you know exactly what function you need
to type in to do that and then you could
always do a help file on any of these
functions to see exactly the syntax that
you need
to be able to write the code correctly
okay
how are we doing here
um difference between load and attach
package
um
i mean there is no attach um so there's
not like attach function in regards to
this um so that's basically i mean these
basically both just
load it um you can't just do an attach
in our
uh for clearing screen there is i
have to remember what the heck it is
though um
let's try it troll there you go
look at these guys
fantastic students
okay
cool um so i think we've gone through
this a few times here in regards to
installing packages so i'm not going to
go through this piece again
but you know essentially there's two
ways to do it once it's point and click
through here actually i guess there's
technically three um
once the point click on here on the
install
one is up here in this top functionality
you can go to install packages which
leads to the exact same link
or my recommendation is going ahead and
putting it in here
okay
so let's go ahead and do our first quiz
so um go ahead and write your answer for
which of the following statements is
true about r
and this is just um
one correct answer
i'm 99 sure uh so r is a proprietary
general purpose language r excels in
statistical computation graphic
capabilities
our syntaxes are very similar to the
assembly language
or are as no graphic user interface
primarily of these on here
um yeah and that's basically what r is
developed as just a statistical tool
with graphing capabilities
it's not an assembly or compiler
language
it's just object oriented
okay
this is just rote memorization what does
crayon stand for comprehensive r network
computational our network comprehensive
r archive network computational r
archive network
all right she's
i think it's all c's okay
see how you guys did
correct comprehensive r archive network
okay
uh so which of the following is not an
ide for r
um
well i bet you guys can guess
our studio our gui 10 r or dreamweaver
okay
and i'm seeing up top
most you guys know that dreamweaver is
primarily used for html and css
so yeah rstudio is the pretty much the
fact of standard ide but if after the
course you don't like using it there are
other ide solutions
um so there's and you know so like uh if
you're a java programmer then you may
already love eclipse and and so since it
has our support functionality you can do
that
okay
so we went through this part pretty
quick but which commands could be used
to browse and access all health
documents in our help that start help
help library or install that packages
help
i'm actually intrigued you guys are
finishing that response
and close this
and help that help actually does
something
huh
interesting
well it does lead
somewhere health is the primary
interface in the health systems oh so it
just leads to the help function okay
um
yeah see your guys point i believe
everyone um
oh we actually had a few answers okay
cool
um so we'll go through what the right
one is and why
okay
um
so help that start
that's the one that gets us to
essentially the front page of all of the
manuals right
so
and you can see it essentially links
directly to this http
doc index for all of the our manuals
reference materials etc
they helped that help did not actually
know that would run
but that functionality leads to
the help utility itself documentation so
not really useful
we also have library which is what we
use to load a package
and then install.packet does help that's
actually part of base r so um this
should not do anything
okay so if we wanted to load and install
a package in r
would we do
load package we do library package would
we do install packages
or would we just do library
so this isn't installing the package but
we're wanting to load a package that
we've already installed
okay
for the most part b
uh might be an a or c in there
um
yep so the load functionality
um we don't use that to load packages um
like i said it would be a better naming
schema but uh when it was created
uh we used library so installer packages
since i saw a couple answers on that as
well this is to actually install it so
that's not incorrect uh this is the
framework that we use
but in regards to actually loading it
and that's what the question asks for we
use the library function and then the
package name
okay so the summary here
r is a programming language developed as
an alternative to the s language that's
just pretty much the fund now ours
available for windows mac and linux
which is really nice if you have
different computers
um ours primary purpose and invention
was for statistical computation and then
we added really good visualizations on
top of that
art does have a steeper learning curve
at first
and um and then we're working with large
data sets you need to remember that
you're limited to the actual amount of
ram you have on your computer
so if you have really large data sets
you're going to have to take some sort
of partition of that some sort of sub
symbol of that to be effective
art can be downloaded from crayon
and then our studio is the ide that
would be downloaded from our studio
our studio um i'm generally going to
recommend running on a desktop so we
don't experience weird um errors if they
don't update their browser in timely
fashion but they do have a built-in web
browser just like jupiter notebook does
for python
so our stores whatever user defined
objects variables classes you put in the
workspace by allowing the user to take a
snapshot of that current workspace and
reloading it into the next time our
starts um so that's a nice piece if you
save it that way
every single r function has its own help
page which is great if you need to
explore or you need to understand what
syntax you need
i also will use google or stack overflow
if there are quarks um
and then not all factors are loaded by
default right and so that's why we may
have to install the packages for
external libraries
and then we'll have to load those
libraries using that function
okay
that's done with that piece
let's um
let's see what time is it 8 10
let's uh let's come back in uh
five minutes um and uh that'll give you
time to play around for a second if you
want to play around and if you have any
questions um you can go ahead and put
those in chat and i will answer those in
five minutes so i want to give you guys
a couple minutes to ingest this material
and then we'll start moving on to this
next section oops
this next section here we go
which will get into the r operators
the arithmetic relational logical and
assignment operators as well as
conditional statements loops uh and
scripts and then some commonly used r
functions uh and then the last thing
that we'll do to end the day we'll kind
of be getting into um the
actual structures of data that we have
so let's take five minutes now and then
we'll come back
all right cool
in real time what's the size of ram we
work on 4r
so uh
you know it kind of just depends um
because file sizes are all over the
place so um
it might only be
you know
100 200 megabytes or i've had r crash on
me before
um
and a lot of times i'll work on hadoop
or aws ecosystems
uh and have r server or something like
spark or h2o on those so that way i
don't really have the rim restrictions
of an actual pc
um you might want to save workspaces
because that way it will
you know load whatever packages you had
loaded up
and you know you don't have to rerun all
the code so if you had ran something
that took two days to run that will
still be safe in working memory instead
of you having to recompute all of that
and then we'll get into saving uh files
you can save in different ways
okay
everyone anyone have any other questions
does everybody here
that's two i want to get at least three
more
okay
uh yep so yeah um our uh itself as well
as you know the csv files as well as
objects you create like all that goes
directly into memory um so none of it
saves on the hard drive or anything like
that so
um
that's why those memory limitations
exist
uh not objects in regards to how you
define them in something like java
but we have classes
so i guess slightly different
yeah no i mean basically yeah basically
almost everything gets loaded directly
in some memory um so that's why you have
to be cognizant of
how much space you're using and
processes
a
terrible example would be something uh
and i can show you a quick picture of
what it looks like
in theory
so um
at an organization i was with
i guess any of these work um
but at an organization i was with
i tried to run a hierarchical clustering
model and you don't need to know what
that is right now we'll get into it
later in this course
but there's different clustering
techniques
and uh and so
uh k-means clustering technique ran in
like
three minutes um on a few million people
but hierarchical clustering gave me an
error message and he told me i needed uh
gigabytes of ram to run
so
um yeah part of it is the object storage
part of it is the file storage and then
part of it is the actual processes
themselves
um so
there are there will end up being
limitations you have to kind of work
around
um
let's wait till we get to classes
themselves they're not necessarily
connected to
functions in some meaningful way
because you can run a lot of different
functions on different
class types but we'll get into the
different classes and be able to specify
those and look at those
okay
so lesson three um so we'll do
40-ish minutes and then take another
quick break and uh and then we'll
continue with the rest of this material
so um in this section we're going to
explain the four types of r operators go
through different types of conditional
statements in arm
we're going to discuss the different
types of loops we can do
and
loops and r
won't necessarily always be optimal
in next week lesson when we get into the
apply functions that's where
our really stands out they tend to be a
lot faster so we often use those instead
of actual loops here
but we're going to go through in regards
to the actual loops and how they work
we'll want to go through some of the
commands running our script and batch
script
you don't necessarily do this too often
but if you were working directly from
the command line or terminal
then or you know trying to run something
on aws that our script would be useful
and then we'll go in through some of the
commonly used r functions
so
there's essentially four types of
operators we have the arithmetic the
relational the logical and the
assignment and we're going to go through
all of these
so arithmetic right
very typical common
operators we have the plus sign for
addition minus sign for subtraction
uh the sign over the 8 the asterisk the
multiplication sign
as for multiplication
forward slots for division if we have an
exponent we can bring that to whatever
power we want
the modulus is in the remainder as well
as the integer division
so if we go ahead
let me
open our studio over here
we'll zoom that in so you guys can do
this as well
just get this over
so
if we just wanted to do three plus five
and we're not worrying about assigning
any variable types or classes or
anything right now we'd run that and we
get eight right so the plus sign works
so you could do three minus five
go ahead and run that negative two
that works as well
we want to do three
times five
fifteen perfect
three divided by five
point six works as well
if we want to do three to the fifth
power
we could run that
243 i believe that's correct 3 9 27 81
yep
and
then let's see we could do three percent
percent
five
and that gives three
and then this three
percent divided by percent five should
give us two
zero
oh integer division okay
um
i think it has to be five divided by
three
okay yeah
so um so this doesn't uh um essentially
rounds off kind of like uh the python
2.7 does
okay
everyone good with those
okay perfect yeah so one is uh remainder
and then one is um the actual just uh
number of times it's divisible by
okay
then we can also do other operators
right so uh we if we want to compare two
different sets of values right so
we have
yeah i mean you know i could say as a
data scientist that i've never once used
that function um
so
like it's not always necessary that you
memorize or completely um fully
understand like every single function we
go through because we're going to go
through a lot
and um you know that's generally not
something that i'll ever need as a data
scientist
so you know take some of this with a
grant salt it's more about that you guys
understand this and then if you really
needed to be able to find it that you
could do that through the help files
through
stack overflow through googling asking
your neighbors in the course so that's
the biggest premise here but this is
just to show the logical operators how
all this works
so if we say 3 is less than 5 that
logical operator will tell us it's true
if we say 3 is greater than 5 it's going
to tell us that we're false
if we say 3 is less than or
equal to 5. what do you guys say it's
going to show
what's the solution to line 40 going to
show us
okay
looks like it's a little bit half and
half so we're saying is
three is less than or equal to five so
if that's true it should print true
if it's false then it would print false
three is less than or equal to five so
it prints true
now
and what does it say here if we do 3 is
greater than or equal to 5.
okay
good
so i think you guys got the hang of this
um you can also do equals um so
there are
two types of operators with equals so if
we do equals um
equals tends to work at like a
functional level um a higher level so
i don't think this will run we'll see
yeah
so because here um it's seen as an
assignment operator at this global
environment we can't say that we're
assigning um five to three right
um so if we work with objects themselves
so something like scalars or within a
vector
you have to use double equal sign
so we say 3 double equal sign 5 and now
it's going to tell us that's false
if we try to say that 3 is not equal to
then that should register is true
because they're not equal
okay
so i think you guys have a good grasp on
that we'll move forward um again you
know stop me anytime if you have
questions
logical operators i rarely work with as
well because i'm generally doing data
cleaning and modeling
but there are the
operators as well
so
you know uh
what's a good example actually i think
we're about to get into an example of
these um how they work but uh you can
have
logical operators so the exclamation
itself just like here is a not operator
so three is not equal to 5
but you can do this with words as well
right so you could have um
like
green is not
it's not equal to red um and it won't
even be equal to green either right
and all outputs y of vector form and
value becomes one
uh so
let's see best way of saying that
um let's just get into nope we don't
have scalars in here okay so the the
biggest reason why is because a
a vector um
or say a scalar is a single number right
so three counts as a scalar
and uh or five or anything you can think
of a single number single character
string whatever that's a a scalar um
type as scalar
but
a
you know a vector is a list right so we
might say that 1 through 10
is a vector i don't even know if i can
run this if i need to run the
concatenate function
okay so this is a vector right
one through ten
and if i just had one
and i try to run that it's just going to
produce one now as you see here you know
it's the the list element that's showing
up here and a scalar is basically a one
by one matrix right it's a one by one
vector
um so that's why you end up seeing that
one show up here because of its
positioning within it
okay
um
so we also have other logical operators
we can do element-wise logical so we
could say um you know
i feel like we get into this in a moment
but um you know if we want to find out
if things are similar and do
some sort of compare contrast
we could say you know um orange or blue
orange or blue just like here
um
and
orange or red and then it would prove
true because oranges in both those
sorry i'm not true
oh you mean like here
yeah it's just because it's the the list
orientation so if um
if this was a list like if we
i'm not gonna do the whole thing but um
for i you know in n or something like
that if if we wanted to go through a um
and this was a
a list of one through ten or something
like that
then it would
the first one for something running like
this is slightly off so don't worry
about it but it would show the one as um
true because three is greater than one
and then it would show
two as true then it would show three is
false fours false five ten through ten
is false um
so it's essentially to show the list
order or the list placement that it's at
so it's just a placement mechanism so
that it's easier for you to find things
okay cool so we have these and or
operators
not used too frequently but
they
can be used as well
in regards to assignment operators
it's always rule of thumb best to assign
to the left so you want the variable
or feature whatever you want to call it
name on the left side
we do the less than sign
dash and then whatever the assignment is
and you know
it can be something like that so we'll
get into what that actually means in a
second but
um
and then if we wanted to print age we
could see that age includes 18 through
50.
and so yeah to the point you know this
would be the 26 row of that uh vector
starts at 43.
uh so yeah you can do this right
assignment but it's not recommended
okay so then we're going to get into if
else statements um we could do regular
if else and nested if else
they do have some strong functionality
but again when we get into the apply
functions
that's where it's going to be much
stronger
and useful
but in regards to how these work
so
let's say we assign
age
instead of 18 to 50 we say age is 20
right
now
let's say we also have this syntax right
if age is greater than 18 print major
else print minor
so if we ran all of this right now
what would the answer show
what would the output be
and feel free to type this as well but
yeah i just want to see what you guys
think the output is for this
okay okay major major um
it should be that i believe
all right if we run that's
where
those two match those two matches to
match
oh i think i need one there and one
there
what am i missing here guys
[Music]
um page print oh i might not actually
need that
okay yep
there we go so we said if age is greater
than 18 print major else print minor and
so it runs through this first
loop here
and it goes h okay so age variable well
eight variables 20. this that plugs that
in here so if 20 is greater than 18
print major well 20 is greater than 18.
so it just stops
now if we had
let's say we did this right we say age
is 10 through 20 it's a vector right
and we can see that here if we print it
right so that's a vector of ages 10
through 20.
and then we ran this
oh that's right we can't always do that
for vectors
okay
uh if else gets funky with vectors when
you try to do that um i always get ahead
of myself and forget
but essentially what it would do is uh
we're just gonna use the apply function
for this but it would iterate through
this right so it would plug in 10 first
so it says tens greater than 18 print
major well it's not so that it goes to
the else statement so it would print
minor so what it would do for the first
seven or first eight it would print
minor and then the last two it would
print major
um
yeah so this is something
r ends up having quarks every now and
then as well
so you get this warning message and if a
greater 18 condition is length greater
than 1 meaning it's not a scalar it's a
vector only the first element will be
used which means all it would use would
be 10.
okay
so let's all go ahead and type this next
one in uh before you run it would love
to know what you think the results are
going to be
and i'm not going to
interpret it out loud this time because
i want you to try to figure that out
make sure you understand the
interpretation of these
so once you think you know what the
answer is going to be on this
go ahead and type it in
okay we got most answers okay so cool so
we assign x to zero
and then we go ahead and print this and
just like everybody said you guys did a
great job um zero is the answer
and uh so again
loop statements work in the way where it
will terminate once it reaches whatever
the actual result is so
um
if x was negative one
right we ran that
and then ran all this code again
it'll say a negative number
and
it should we'll see if this works um yep
so we could just run this statement here
um if x is less than zero print negative
number
because uh the way that it's operating
is solely based on
sequential order so it first checks if x
is less than zero print negative number
if it hits it it's done
um if not it'll move to this next else
if statement um
so elsif is like elif on python
so we'd say okay well x isn't negative
let's see if x is positive then i can
print positive number
oh x isn't positive either else print
zero so
great job guys on that
okay
and then um
let's see
the if-else
statement we kind of just went through
so
the c function we'll get into in a
second but it's essentially concatenate
or combined
so if we ran that first one printed a
you can see it's now a vector of string
or of integers one two three four
if we want to run this if else
should work um
so if any of you have ever worked with
excel before kind of the same premise on
this line
um
perfect okay
so if a divisible by two leaves a
remainder of zero then it's even
otherwise it's odd right so it's
checking one divisible by two has a
remainder of zero um well no it's not
even because this uh
remainder typically is negative one so
it's odd two divided by two has a
remainder of zero so it's even
so there's a lot of functionality that
can be done in r
compared to
using multiple different softwares
okay so switch is one that i actually
learned uh recently i had never used it
before but it's actually pretty
interesting right
so
we see it as a controlled branch of else
statements
and
so the
second line will be more interesting for
us all to run um you might just want to
type that in
but this first line
um you can see it essentially looks for
the placement
and then we'll run essential uh um if
else statements throughout this so
if we assign
the color green
um
and this is a an error right here um it
needs to be green
in quotation marks so we assign green
to the variable color
and technically we should do the arrow
assignment right
so we run this
we can print color and we see that it's
green
so then we go to swift function and we
go to color which means technically this
is the word green right
and
let's see if we can slide this over for
you guys a little more room
so
we have switch color and that is going
to give a few options so what we're
doing here is saying okay um
i guess i won't write all this out but
the way this is operating is it's saying
okay well take this variable you know
whether it's a scalar a vector
and we're going to run this
on these different functions and so okay
if
the color is red then we're going to
print apple if color here this function
shows up as yellow then we're going to
print the word banana
or
especially elsif or else
color is green then it'll print avocado
so based on this what are you guys going
to see printed
perfect you guys get it
great minds okay so yeah it would print
avocado because essentially it's just
cycling through until it finds the one
that works
okay
so then we can do these uh for loops uh
which is kind of uh
the most common we can also do while
loops and then we can do repeating loops
so
a for loop is done an explicit number of
times right
so if we go ahead and create a vector
called vec
and then we concatenate one two three
four and five
or you can also do
one colon five
and we run that
then we'll see that it prints back one
through five right
and this says for val in invec print
valve
now this isn't really going to produce
anything interesting for us
because we already know what those
values are but if we had some sort of
index attached to that right so instead
of just the value we asked it to you
know take the first 10 rows but they all
had names it would print those names up
but essentially the for loop iterates
through
what however many are in whatever the
for loop actually entails so here it
would run five times because in vec
there are five numbers one two three
four and five
now in a while loop
you can see
let's make this bigger for you um test
expression remains true the code inside
the loop keeps on executing right so
that means it does not stop unless you
specify a stop as long as the test
expression remains true
so if we assign the letter i
to a scalar of
one then we say while i is less than six
print i
and then make i equal to i plus one
so do you guys have an idea of what's
going to print out here
awesome great job guys yep so
essentially you know it would uh print
one because it's normally one and it's
less than six so then it prints one and
then we say i equals one plus one now
it's two then it cycles back through
well two is less than six print two
and uh and so until it hits six that's
what's going to iterate
uh the thing you have to be careful of
with while loops
is that if there isn't some sort of part
stop then it's going to keep looping
forever and if there is any sort of
memory leak then it'll end up crashing
on your r studio system at some point
so you have to make sure you either put
in a hard break
or you know that it's only going to
iterate a set amount of times like in
this case
so the other piece is that there's
repeat loops they can iterate code
multiple times
um
and if there aren't the conditional
checks to exit the loop you have to
specify inside the body of the loop
right
so here it would be the same thing so
if we did a repeat as the for loop with
x assigned to one
it would print one and then it would say
one plus one equals two
and then if two is equal to six then
break well it's not equal to six so then
it'll repeat back through print two two
plus one equals three if three is equal
to six nope okay so we loop back through
and
you know so if we didn't have this break
in here
based on this code do you guys know what
you would see
or i guess we should just say these
first three lines repeat print and x
equals x plus one
so if we ran this what would you see
yeah great job uh uh michelle scott and
who need yeah it would be infinite
because every single time we're
increasing that iteration plus one and
so this would essentially keep around on
your computer and
um essentially we'll you know every bite
will increase that so that at some point
it'll crash your r system so you want to
make sure that if there are potential
for infinite loops then yeah that breaks
going to cause that's why we need that
break in there
so you know the same thing just uh like
i was just talking about when inside
that loop those brakes actually stop the
iteration from executing um so you can
have hard brakes in there or you can
have if brakes in there
uh
so manish it would go so this is
basically a for loop right the repeat
function um is a for loop
and so if we originally assigned x for
one then we're saying okay print one
and then we say one plus one equals two
so now repeat that print two two plus
one equals three repeat that print three
three plus one equals four so it's just
going to keep iterating higher and
higher because there is no limit
we're not talking about running this
piece this piece doesn't exist now we
were only talking about running these
three lines and because there's no
parameter that specifies a stop point
like x equals six
or x running a hundred times
then it'll keep going
yeah i was talking about without running
this so this this long this will just
run one through five
i'm sorry one through six
no one through five
so yeah what you were talking about was
correct with with these with this line
in here
okay
so i think you guys get how breaks work
um
so next could be skipping current
iterations of a loop i don't think i've
ever used the next function so i
probably wouldn't worry about it but
if you want to potentially skip a value
or some function then you could do that
as well
okay
full screen for a minute
so
um we'll go ahead and do this together
so there are
let's open up a new script here
so there's going to be a number of
different ways to read in data uh and it
depends on the file type but r can read
in most every file type including things
like spss or other legacy files
um
[Music]
oh that's from the council
um
yeah
yeah we're not going to read them from
that directly so
if we want to specify something um and
we can type this in here
http
colon 404 slash www.ats.ucla.edu
forward slash stat forward slash data
course by scan dot text
and uh and then i think
let me put parameters in here as well um
since i've worked with this data set
we'll include those parameters
what equals lift
i'm saying h equals zero name
equals double paren
so i'm not quite sure what this will run
because i don't work with this data set
before
but it looks like it just the scan
you know essentially reads the number of
rows and just gives you a count of the
records um we're going to have other
things like read.table read.csv that'll
actually be used for
reading the files but
um
you know in regards to say you had
something with you know 10 million
records you want to do the scan to make
sure that r would you know conceivably
say okay it looks like we have 10
million records here because if it only
says that it read
500 records then you know there's
something wrong likely with the data
because it hasn't been ingested or
anything yet
it just was a quick scan of the number
of rows
okay
so we can also use uh source
so there are is that like read that text
as well um so you may end up using that
but when we're looking to run our
scripts themselves
uh i can type this into the chat
so uh that's typed into chad but yeah i
ran it down here and you can see it just
shows that it read four records
so that the scan is essentially just in
the account right of the number of
records in that case
um since we don't have uh
our file saved right now
i'll just kind of instruct you through
how this works
but the source function is instructing
art to read the text file and execute
its content
so basically what you have up here this
is technically a text file i mean it's a
r file but you can read it via like
notepad or something um and so the
source file is saying okay so i called
my script my script.r or i called mine
test1.r right
and so if i wanted to run that
especially if you're like trying to run
that on like an aws server or you go to
the
command line or terminal and try to run
that
that would be the best way
now the cool piece is that this function
has something called echo and if you set
echo to true
so say it was this entire script here
if i didn't include echo it wouldn't
print all of this out it would just
print whatever the results are so these
ones that we see and whatnot that's what
it would show
what the echo does is it will print up
all of this as well to let you know
what's actually running um so it's a
good feature to know and have
if you don't know that though or don't
remember
we can do
camera sources and bass i think it's in
bass so that should run right
okay yep sources and bass um
so single question mark works
it reads our code from a file or
connection
and look at all these other parameters
you can do so we just told you about one
which is just echo
but there's all these other parameters
you can include as well and you can see
here echo
is a logical function which means it's
just true or false if true each
expression is going to be printed after
parsing before evaluation so it's going
to print all of this before parsing it
apart and running each section of this
piece so that's pretty cool
you could do the same you could limit it
with this print that you val blah blah
but again you know there's so many
functions within r that there's no way
that you should necessarily try to
memorize all of them um the more that
you operate into space the more that you
go oh okay well the c function and one
um colon five means i'm concatenating
the integers one through five into a
vector like that's something that i know
how to do um because it happens often
enough but something like source with
echo it doesn't happen as frequently
right you're saving those files and
running them as bad scripts a lot less
so don't necessarily worry about
memorizing all of the functional
features in here
as long as they make sense to you and
what we're doing
and then the same thing you can do a
command line batch script so if you had
a set of codes that you wanted to run in
some sort sequential order you can do
that
um and all these can run directly from
the command line
it's uh it's relatively rare unless
you're at an organization that
like the hadoop interface doesn't
interface with uh rstudio or our studio
server and so you need to run these
batch scripts here and access our studio
somewhere on site
so this will be less common in the real
world but when you productionize
and i say that because when you
productionize in the real world
uh a lot of your r script may end up
going to a data engineer and you'll say
okay these are the 20 features we need
to focus on this is the model
and they may actually recode that in
java or something that's more optimal
for
a productionized environment
so a lot of times you won't end up
having these batch scripts that you're
running all the time
are still used in production but
if
you know organizations are looking to
optimize speed uh the majority of our um
packages run on like
c and c plus plus so they are really
fast but there are some things that take
a lot longer that would be faster in
something like java c sharp what not so
it'll kind of just depend on the
organization you work with if you need
to worry about any sort of batch
scripting or running these source files
okay
i think
yep
all right
so
we're going through this fast okay
um actually i guess before we get into
this since it's five minutes from our
normal break um
let's go ahead and take 15 minutes um
i'll
you know
sit around here answer any questions you
guys have during that time
but uh
basically
all we're going to have is going like
left is going through these sets of
functions so we'll play around with this
a little bit
and and then a little bit of data
structures we're actually just going
into vectors today so there's not too
much more again you know um i sometimes
talk fast so i'm happy to go back
through anything i'm happy to stay here
and talk with you guys with any
questions you have as well um even after
the course uh for today and but let's go
ahead we'll come back at 10 minutes past
the hour
or if you don't have daily savings i
think that's uh 40 minutes past the hour
and so basically about 15 minutes now
and then we'll go through these lists of
about 20 functions have a quiz go
through vectors and then i will stay um
for any questions that you guys have as
well
so i'll be here for any questions now
but otherwise go ahead and take a
15-minute break and then we'll come back
so
and it might be dependent on where the
location is saved
let's clear that window
so we want to do source um
and then i named my script test1r
true
let's see if that runs
oh okay
um
you know take that line out
okay let's save that
again uh and that's another piece for
you guys to know as well
if you do
type something into the command line or
the console um to play around with it
and uh you decide that it's actually
important you can kind of scroll up and
using the up and down ears to scroll
back through um recent syntax things you
did and so if i wanted to to copy this
come paste it here as well
um
let's see so we have some error messages
here so we have these
save
this
and then now let's see if this runs
okay
oh i don't need okay cancel that
uh cancel
[Music]
yeah sorry i have a lot of things in
here right
let's see so we don't want to install
this package again um
anything else we don't want to install
that package again
let's see
okay so that should be good now right
okay
so
we're doing source running test one dot
r equal equals true so what it should do
is print all of uh this and run all of
this
so if we run that
here you go it's printing
all of these functions
and i'm still getting that
oh that's because i made it a vector
okay
oops
okay here we go
so that's what you're seeing there right
um
it's printing all of
the actual functions um so it originally
printed just the syntax which is all of
this
here you can see the switch color
um
and here you know it's not actually
running the calculations on
those but then
here you know we have these vectors so
it's running all of those
um so echo true just runs solar code is
doing yeah so if we don't include echo
so if we set echo to false
then you see it's just printing out the
results themselves so you don't
necessarily know what the syntax is
according to
it's just printing out whatever the
results were for those things
yeah so it's essentially like if you um
the the real world case would be you
know say you built a model uh to cluster
your customer base
um
that you could just go in and say like i
don't need to do run these 800 different
tests to know that i know the model is
this and so i just can run this script
right here
which might just be like another six
lines of code for running that model
to cluster the individuals in your
customer base
all right cool
so um we'll do this uh two ways um
the first is we'll generate a little
sequence to play around with and then
i pulled up something that
you guys can play around with after we
get through the rest of the course
material i'll walk you quickly through
it it says diamonds data set um pretty
commonly used
so
close these up for a second here
so we're gonna do
is okay
uh and one of the interesting things
that you can see here
is that i can open up a
new r script it'll be clean but the
council still exists what's what values
you have those all still exist right so
um
if you want to keep different things in
different uh
our syntax files that's perfectly fine
you want everything together that's fine
too
so
um
let's name a vector vector one
and call it c one two three four five
so if we run that
we wanna print that to verify it one
through five
and so what this is basically saying is
we decided to name a vector
you can call it a list that i call it a
vector in this case
and we're concatenating
integers one two three four and five
right
so
if we didn't know how the append
function work
what is something we could do to figure
out um what we could what would
potentially be included in this
parentheses
how do you guys figure that out
[Music]
so i'll give you guys a second to
respond there but yeah so if we don't
know what to do for a pen
what ways could we go about looking at
it
to know what we could include in this
help file here
okay
very healthy pen and
question mark append right
all right so we run that
so
this is the append argument this should
produce the same thing right
okay
um and so it looks like here
the append has essentially um the the
main
aspect and then the filters on top of
that
so the vector to be modified right so
maybe we want to modify our current
vector so append vector one right and
what values might we want to include
well maybe we just want to add 6 on top
of there right
so then if we go ahead and run this
oh we actually have to do an assignment
here okay so
um
so we essentially want to
add the number six
to vec one
and so the way this will work is we're
using the append function
on vec1 so that vector we had which is
this up here concatenating one through
five adding six on top and then we're
calling that vect1 now we could call
this you know vector if we want to right
so
we'll call this back two just to show
you what existed here so we run this now
vectors in here is numbers one through
six not numbers one through five
now if i called this vect one and i ran
this
you can watch right here on this row
now it's one through six right
so depending on how you label this
uh because if i
just ran this a pen one through six it's
there but then how would i access that
so i can't just
if i printed um let me rerun this here
right
so vec one one through five right and if
i
ran this
append back one six and then ran this
it's back down to one through five so we
have to do is assign it to some sort of
vector
okay cool
so well we'll leave one as one through
five vector is now that append on six
right
now let's also do a
let's do vector
three and here we're going to
concatenate and then i'm going to give
you that shortcut
so let's do let's make it fun right
let's do 1 through 100 so this is saying
give me all the integers 1 through 100
and assign it to vector 3. so we run
that
and now it's an integer with
vector numbers 1 through 100
right
if we wanted to print that out we could
do that here you see numbers one through
100 right
it's a very cool very easy function
um
identical i've probably
never used before
so you know i've been doing data science
for 10 years so there's always new
things to learn so don't be overwhelmed
if you don't know and so i go in here to
the helper
do identical okay it's inbase and they
can return true or false and only if
it's exactly true
so
what we might have is any r objects um
so let's see if instead of just scalars
if it works with vectors right
so let's go ahead and say
we want to compare vect1 and vector
right because we know ones one through
five and one's one through six
i don't actually know if this will work
or if it only works for scalars
false
so it works with vectors as well it
should work with matrices and data
tables as well
and what it's doing is just comparing
the entire structure of this
and you know it could be as a name as
one's numeric and one's integer and it
might show up as false um you could have
this as a character string instead of
numeric um here and even though
and actually that would be an
interesting one to see right is if uh
vec on mine because that shows his aunt
and vect1 as num which is one through
five if those will register as true or
false or if it's just the character
classes themselves
or
what's within the string
false and that's because the numbers are
the same but the character class is
different
if you want to append three values on
one shot not a certain sequence um
you know so like uh uh yeah you know i i
sometimes i don't know right because uh
i'm generally working with very large
data sets and i'm not actually pending
because it's done on the etl extraction
process generally um we can see if this
works
unused argument okay
um
so can we append
more
than one feature at a time
because it does say values so it's
likely that this needs to
maybe be within another set of parens
we'll see if that works
and that still doesn't work
maybe it doesn't include commas we can
see if that
unexpected numeric constant
um
yeah so that's something i can research
because i was trying to i know that you
could do this functionality but i didn't
know if you could do disparate numbers
like you're talking about
um
so i will write a note for myself as
well for our next class
because i'll end up googling around to
see if there's a way to do that one of
the most one of the ways you can be the
most effective data scientist
is if you
um
get really proficient at googling
because what people are going to do is
assume you know how to do everything
so no matter what the space is anything
related to data data cleaning data
merging data munching data modeling um
and productionizing there's the
assumption that data scientists can do
all that and you know you can see just
from you know day two of this course
there's a ton of functions and you may
never have used them before and that's
perfectly fine
um so a lot of that piece ends up being
googling around to find the right
answers so you know what i may end up
doing is going in and saying um append
function in our
um
[Music]
unique numbers or something like that
and it may take a little bit of work to
try to find some sort of append that
works
because there's pi there's after five
um
yeah so it might just be you know for
this case and again i'll end up looking
around a little bit because i want to
find out but it might be that you have
to do multiple appends right
um
so you might not be able to do it
necessarily within that single append
function itself
and that's okay too
okay
so identical we've tested
we understand that
it tests essentially whether it's a
scalar vector
a matrix whether two are exactly the
same in class and what they contain
so let's use vect3 for the next few
right
so if we want to return the length of
the r object back three
we could go here effect three
there's a command two for selecting the
most recent line and i just forgot what
it is
um
so we know especially because it's an
integer that vect3 has 100 numbers in it
and when we test the length we see that
it has a hundred produced as the output
um
might not be as useful for something
that's an integer or numeric that's so
easy to
look at and just have a count but you
know say you had a list of character
strings
this would be a really nice way to get a
count of how many are in there
the next function uh that ends up being
really useful you you may end up using
it pretty often is list um shown as ls
and so if we wanted to go ahead and run
that
we'll see i have a age color
gcc torture i don't even remember
running that variable uh valve one
vector of x3 and x
and so just like you can see it here in
my global environment you could do that
via a list so whatever way is easier for
you to look at it
is one of the
i guess best mechanisms but
that's why our studio is a useful tool
because you can see those snapshots
right there if you are working in r
itself the only way you can see the
variables is using this ls function
so
this here says that range
returns the minimum and maximum of the
vector
so if we're running vect3
what numbers
is going to be printed out
are going to be printed out
okay
so just like you guys said boom right
there one to 100.
and so um we'll get into some of the uh
summary types of statistics and whatnot
um a little bit later in the class um
and uh you guys will see like ways of
looking at that data
but if there are things you need to look
at just like for this right so if if we
thought
let's say this was a questionnaire and
people could only answer on you know um
1 to 100
but when i typed range this showed up as
1 million as the largest number then we
know there's something erroneous with
the data and so there's a lot of things
that we do for data validation and
checks
before we even really start working with
the data
so we need to know you know what each uh
set of uh things in a vector what
variables in a vector or a matrix should
entail and then we can sort of validate
against those to make sure they're
accurate that's why i like 60 to 80
percent of a data scientist time is
supposedly spent with the data cleaning
and exploration process
okay so one of the cool ones uh
functions
is uh are these uh rep and sequence
features
um rep is just repeat
so if we wanted to repeat the number x
in time so let's say we want it uh
five ten times right
and we could run that you see the number
five constantly repeating that's an easy
way to create like an identity matrix or
something in that regard now you know if
we wanted to be able to access this
later then we need to assign that to a
variable name so we would call that
vect4
run that and then if we want to access
that later we can just type x4 and then
boom there's those fives
and that's how we can end up using it to
you know if we wanted to compare effect
one to vec four
we have to have those variable
assignments there
um
interesting
rev function right
so we go ahead and run rev
it says it provides a reverse function
of its argument
so if
a vector is sorted in a particular way
now when we get into the apply functions
there's a better sorting mechanism but
you know if you wanted to sort 1 through
10 from 10 through 1
instead of
if we had vector 5
and set it's one through ten
print that out
we see it's one through ten
instead of reassigning five to be you
know
a concatenation of
through 1.
we could instead do this reverse
function right which would be
effect five
so
here we'll run this
and now we print x5 and now it's in
reverse order
so
um not always necessary in regards to
the data science aspect but it can be
useful in regards to um pairing up
different vectors together
let's see the sequence function is also
really great right so
let's say
we did
so we don't have to uh reverse the data
in vector five um that there's not
always necessarily utility for it which
is why i said interesting because i
don't use the reverse function either um
because as a data scientist it's really
about cleaning and understanding the
data which means you're looking at a lot
of the structure and summary statistics
doing correlation and scatter plots to
understand what the data
relationships look like as well and
distributions
so generally you're working in a matrix
as a data scientist for a data frame a
data table
they're all pretty synonymous
so it's kind of just like an excel file
would be
so you're generally not needing to
reverse something like this but if for
some reason you did need to reverse
some sort of list then this is one of
the easier ways to do it um generally
what you're going to do is some sort of
apply function which you know you say
but uh wouldn't be a vector array to be
a matrix and uh and then you know sort
by age or something like that
and so that's what you would more
commonly see and then you can kind of
look at patterns within that um but if
you need to necessarily
alphabetize something or something in
that regard then uh the reverse function
could be useful
so in regards to the don't worry about
supply right now in regards to the
sequence function right so it says it
generates a regular sequence from x to y
space by n
so let's say
i put these three numbers in
what would you guys expect the output to
be
so
okay got a few answers let's go ahead
and run and see right
all right
so you see the numbers down here right 1
1.1 1.2 all the way through 2.
so what is sequence doing
it's saying
let's take all numbers between
one and two inclusive right it includes
one and two
and let's take it by a step of point one
which means let's add
point one to one
until it reaches 2.
does that make sense to you guys
so
and the reason this is really useful
if you were if we're not doing random
sequence right
so
let's say
we wanted to create a let's call it
vector six right
um and we wanted to create a vector but
you know one through ten isn't uh we
don't want it we just want the evens so
let's say we want one through um 100 but
only the evens
then we'd say
the min and the max that one through 100
inclusively
by twos
and so we go ahead and type that up
print the output of x6
oh and sorry
because i did it by twos but started at
one um it's going to do all the odds in
that space i could have started at two
run that
print that and now you have it by twos
um
so yeah it just depends on if uh if
you're creating some sort of uh
vector or matrix uh addition
and you need some sort of you know
interesting sequence like this um
because it's you know imagine that
it's
one two oops
imagine that it's one two
one
[Music]
a million by sevens
so for whatever reason your boss says
hey i need you to compile a list um and
maybe he expects you to do it in excel
um of uh
all the number sequences and maybe we'll
just start at seven or eight um
and so if we try to run this this may
actually take a second or it's really
quick okay
um
so then if i want to print vect6 uh and
you'll actually get a max print uh
because i'm pretending a million but you
know these are all those numbers by
seven so he would have that list so it
really just depends on what you're doing
um it's kind of more of a data
engineering or manipulation type thing
but it is a useful tool
and then unique is also unique is pretty
commonly you use and that's because
you're looking to remove duplicate
entries from the vector
so
let's say um
we have another vector vector seven
right
and we say it's one two two three four
five six
eight
eight eight
and ten
so we go ahead and uh run this as is
oops what did i do open cabinet sorry
okay so we concatenate that
we verify the vector contains the right
numbers perfect okay
so
now our boss tells us that
she wants
only the unique numbers in that one
so we go okay we can do that so we'll
call it x7 again
but this time
we want the unique from the original
vect7
and we run that
now i print by 7 again and it's only the
unique numbers so that can be really
really useful um it should work for
character strings as well
so if you wanted to
create like categorical variables say we
have the colors like blue red and green
then um
and but instead of just three you know
there's a hundred different colors then
we could get all the unique um uh
factors all the unique variables and and
then do like count by those or something
everybody good on this page
okay
great great
so
second one right before the quiz okay
we have a couple more things we can do
i'll open up a new one
new our script right
so again all this is still in my global
environment still have all these
different vectors
so let's say um
let's call it color right
and
we have color as green all caps
okay um
vlookup functionality so
uh yeah there's something called uh
crosstabs
and uh and across tables as well as some
of the summary statistics that can do a
lot of what vlookup does
um and tends to be a lot faster too so i
mean there's less of the dragging and
dropping but you can look at things
spliced apart
and again you know like uh
like i say you know the biggest thing is
that we're able to google um so
and and i probably do this every single
day right so we look up an r great idea
that would be great
okay stack overflow one of the most
common um
used resources in regards to this
so data set was too large for excel they
have a categorical variable they like to
assign to a number so with the vlookup
they would just do this
okay over here
they're talking about reading the table
so you're reading that file in
you're saying these text house types
blah blah blah and then you can create
this lookup table so you have these
unique functions
this is actually a lot more complex than
it needs to be
[Music]
but essentially there's a lot of ways of
doing those vlookups so look r for excel
user is great
so you could go into here
and then that's the concatenation on top
of that the header command will get into
these are the joins merges
anyhow
so there's uh there's tons of
information out there and you know this
course and myself will continue to be a
resource but um pretty much anything you
can do and any other tool you can end up
doing in our you just have to read
through
different websites to see so you see
here like the merge command ends up
being really useful and you can have the
buy parameter used for any sort of
sorting mechanisms and clustering that
you need
okay
so
color green and again i should use the
arrow
indicator to do that assignment
okay
so we assign color to green
they always want to validate boom it's
there that's great right
so
we'd want to do maybe uh we'll end up
wanting so we have all these uh um
comments from people but some people
write in all caps some people write in
um uh normal sentence format some people
write in all lowercase some people write
capitalizing the first letter of every
word
and so what we might want is a common
theme and so you know this this could be
done for a vector as well
so
what we
might want to do is um
so in this case let's just call this
color one
and we want to to lower case the entire
vector even though it's only scalar here
lowercase
this variable so anything that's in
variable color which means to lowercase
green um we'll do that right
and then if we print color one now we
see that it's lowercase
we could do the reverse too
so color two
to upper
uh
color one right
we run that
color two now it's capital
um so i mean the the primary purpose
this is used is again um maybe you have
a vector and you want to ensure that you
can
group accordingly because you want to
have counts of the number of people who
wrote the specific colors but
uh r is seen green and green and green
and
green as all different and so you know
uh and there's other ways of uh doing
this as well because we can end up
stripping white space we can but you
know the ideal is that we go ahead and
we have to put
quotations around all these but we'd
want all of these to lower and then if
we did count unique counts we would get
four greens instead of one of each of
these types of greens that's the
important purpose for this
um i
loathe regular expressions if you're
good at them i commend you
um
but they are really useful i've used it
like with merck pharmaceutical and other
clients
and the way that it works is essentially
grep and all of these different
functions are regular expressions
and so if you look for argument patterns
um you can use sub and g sub
and it's probably best that i just go to
a real world example here
so you can see what this kind of looks
like
so
yeah so regular expressions if you've
never used them i'm trying to find one
that's actually good for you guys
um okay yeah it'll contain um let me
zoom in for you
so what you might have is let's say you
have a matrix and one of the variables
so one of the columns has some character
strings in it and you want to extract it
right so maybe you watch
qriket
and
and you know it's uh and this variable
column will say like
um
uh
person one
um
you know
scored
person two strikeout blah blah blah
right
and uh and so you want to parse apart
this first piece
so that's where grep becomes really
useful that's where regex is useful you
can extract basically anything out of a
character string
and so you know if you want to only
extract uh uppercase or lowercase if you
have uh you know spaces that you want to
be ignored or not ignored um so what you
might do for that player one because
there's a space after it is um you know
you might
be extracting them
slash slash s which means like i want to
extract all that's before um this space
and uh and then we could end up
assigning that
um you know a new variable so
and the way we'd end up doing this i'm
getting a little ahead of myself i'm
just excited to show you guys but you
know um let's say our data table was
called cricket right so we had loaded
that so then we would want to create um
we didn't have the players names in
there so we're extracting it from the
text and so we call the new variable
player
and then we're running that grip
function
um you know pulling from the text
feature
and then running all of this
so it's really really useful um regex is
a little bit harder to learn um it's
no no one i know like loves it it's not
necessarily easy to learn um
but and i'll type these two in here for
you if you want to play around with
regex
these two
tutorials um are pretty good
so
a lot of data scientists don't
necessarily know how to do that you know
and again like you can see oh look at
all that that's
really confusing um it's not necessarily
easy or intuitive but it's really really
strong and useful once you become
effective with regex
we won't really touch it too much in
this course for anyone concerned
okay
cool
so um
here's what we're going to do
where did i open
okay
so what i want everyone to do um
and actually we'll kind of expedite this
i'm going to put this all in here and
then i'll copy and paste it into chat
for you guys
because i want us all to work from the
same space
okay
let's make sure everything's running on
here
okay perfect all right so if you could
run these three lines of code
install that packages gdplot2
librarytvlet2 and data diamonds
and then let me know once yours looks
like this where the date of diamonds
looks like it ran no error messages
and then we'll move forward
so cool
[Music]
thanks manish
yeah so i'll tell you about the diamond
dataset in a second um
what it means is uh
masking occurs that sometimes there's
multiple functions uh so sometimes
they've been loaded or sometimes
uh they have issues so margin may
the margin function itself may have some
issue with another package that's
currently loaded
so the way that r handles that is it
essentially
doesn't load that specific function
and that way you won't have any random
errors pop up
did not load
um
and you guys ran uh
the install and the library and loaded
the library gt plot two
those three lines
huh
interesting
did not load
did you get some sort of error message
scott
library duty part two
um
packages let's see cs fan pack
okay
warnings are okay
um
[Music]
this guy did you do the install that
package this cd plot 2 as well
i i know you said you did but it should
load if you've ran that line
and sometimes uh
you know the best solution for you guys
is uh if if there's tons of error
messages popping up and whatnot not just
warnings
but issues that
are can every now and then be quirky you
can just close out of our studio
you can save our data and then can
open and load it back up
the reason i'm having you guys do this
is because uh after the course if you
want you can play around with it ran one
by one okay
um
because i mean you can see i got warning
messages as well margin the r version
built into gd plot 2 but yeah if you if
you guys can at least run the install
that packages ggplot2
and that works then the others should
work
if this line isn't working then we have
an issue
yeah
um i'll go to in a second it's uh one of
the most common data sets uh
the other two um
that you know if you like looking at
blogs or tutorials um to supplement what
you're learning here
uh the diamonds data set is extremely
popular the iris dataset and the titanic
dataset
so all three of those have really clean
data and are used in a lot of blogs so
if you like practicing
then that's one way to handle it
oh yeah i think about uh that just means
that
yep yeah it's loaded uh it just means
because every time there's a like every
single
package can update whenever they want
that's just showing um all the updates
they do gg plus 2 is one of the most
updated because it's all of the
visualization tools and they're
constantly improving it
but within it uh the ggplot2 itself they
actually have a data set called diamonds
that's loaded in there
um
so the way to check that all this is
done
and working is view with a capital v
and then diamonds
and what that should do is produce a
data table a data frame
so let me know if you guys got that to
appear
uh
i mean you should get something like
this in regards to loading the library
but then if you run the view diamonds
let me show you something like this
oh yeah scott so yeah um
what you may end up needing to do
i think it's in global options um
packages is that right
might be in our general
um
where is it
yeah scott there's something in there um
we can play around with that uh after
we finish going through this little bit
but uh there should be a way that you
can save it um so it won't just
necessarily save
to the app data folder um you can
specify where those save
um
because yeah i mean we're not going to
into details we're not like building any
models or anything so um and i can
always share their syntax too okay
so no output uh varchase what do you
mean
yeah that that function is case
sensitive lowercase view won't work
yeah so pretty much all functions are
lowercase for some reason vue is not
okay
oh
yep
actually when i run the um
the i am able to install the package but
after that when i run the couple of uh
you know
commands library
and data i'm not getting any output
actually
uh so library and data might not produce
any output um because uh library won't
produce any output other than maybe
attaching package um because these are
warnings um so you might notice
and data doesn't produce anything that's
why i wanted you to run this view
diamonds to see if you get this output
up here
no i i ran in both the commands that i
understand library attaches and then
data when you run data and diamonds what
is the expected result of that when you
run the command
nothing all it's doing is loading uh
data into the global environment all
it's doing is loading
okay
are you good there
yep okay perfect
okay cool
so
what we're gonna do now um so our
diamonds data sets loaded right
and i'll uh i'll copy and paste
what i type in here as well for you guys
at the end since i know a handful of you
might have issues
so
now this is a data set right this is
what we're generally going to work with
as data scientists and there's certain
things that we're going to want to do
here so we want to look at the summary
of diamonds so if we run this
now we can see that we get
each of the variable names
that we have so if we looked at the data
set carrot cut color clarity etc so
everything that's uh um at the top
we get each of those
and then it's inspecting whether that's
a numeric an integer a character class a
factor variable
and it's going okay
so
this is numeric so we're going to give
the minimum the maximum
the first and third quartiles the mean
and the median
cut is going okay well these are factor
variables right there's five different
factors fair good very good premium and
ideal and these are the number within
cut that fall into each of those
categories
so summary is a way to kind of get a
glimpse of what this
is right and so
you know if we saw the price
the minimum 326 but if it's maximum say
it was you know
a hundred million well that's very
unlikely that there's a diamond that's
selling for a hundred million dollars so
then we could go in and inspect and try
to figure out what the heck's going on
there uh you know we'd expect these
distributions to kind of be similar in
regards to clarity
so if there was you know a clarity that
was uh there were only two cases and
then another that had 30 000 cases then
there might be some issue with the data
so this is one of the ways that we go
and initially inspect this data
the other
really fun way to do that
for this data set is structure str
so when we run structure
what we get is a really cool summary
type statistic right so we're looking at
this data and there's a couple things it
tells us
um it tells us we have a data frame
tells us there are 53 940 cases and
there's 10 variables
and then this is basically the header
this is the first set of variables right
these numbers at the end
but the cool piece is that for each
variable it also tells you the class
so carrot is saying it's a number cut is
saying it's an ordered factor
five levels in a meaningful order um you
can have factor variables that don't
have some sort of order say like uh
colors right
so if we had green red and blue there's
no order to those so they don't need to
be specified as ordered variables
but for these we know that like color
increases right so we'd want that to be
ordered variables
we could look at the depth numeric
numeric integer on price numeric numeric
numeric and so this is one of those
things where if you know that like the
price is supposed to be an integer
and it shows as a factor or a character
then that's a problem so this is another
way for us to inspect the data to make
sure everything's working appropriately
um compact okay
glimpse i very rarely use speak and i
don't think it'll run right now i think
i have to load the plier um so i won't
make you guys do this but we can just
see what it looks like okay so what i'm
going to do real quick
the plier is essentially a cleaning
package
so it's a great way for data munching
data wrangling
and we're going to see what glyphs ends
up looking like with it because i just
normally use summary and structure view
and a few other ones
but so we load library
it's loading it
and dplyer i think we'll end up using
next saturday as well
all right
taking longer than normal hopefully
everything's okay there
all right um
is the data getting picked from package
uh but yeah i mean that's why we had to
load gdp plot two um the diamonds data
set is hosted in gd plot two otherwise i
might have to you have you do like a
read csv and also other stuff okay
so deep plier actually took a while to
install that's okay
it's masking these other things that's
okay
it's optimized for version 3.3.2
so we'll try glimpse see how that runs
all right
so
glimpse works uh relatively the same a
little bit cleaner right so account of
the number of observations number of
variables
and then if it's a double
which is basically numeric an integer or
ordered variable
so we have all these options as well
uh let's see so we can go ahead and do
the class of the object
so i i tend to just use um the structure
and summary but you know if you wanted
to load deep flyer get a glimpse you
like this better that's perfectly fine
as well
class uh
you're not worrying about too much but
it shows you essentially what's hosted
within diamonds
we don't necessarily see all of these
we're only seeing one of them
the mode
some other diamonds uh i don't use mode
so
we can see what else it entails um it
says that the diamonds is a list
but we want to verify and see what else
it could be
so
mode of that you can get or set the type
of storage mode of an object
so how can you do that well you can do
an as.new mode and it could be you know
as logical as integer blah blah blah
so those are much more common using the
mode function not so much but if you had
a
you know if one of your vectors
so let's say we ran the structure again
and
we see here
that
um
price is an integer
what we could technically do if it's
supposed to be a character string or we
want it to be for some reason
is
you know we could do
as character diamonds dollar sign price
and then it will convert the price
variable in the diamond data set to a
character string and so you can do this
to convert things to logical to numeric
and a lot of times to analyze data you
have to do that r can be quirky in that
regard so if something isn't running
then you might want to go and check the
structure um so yeah if price had uh if
price had actually shown up as a
character string and we know it needs to
be
you know an integer
you could do as integer you could do as
numeric and now it can actually be used
in some models um character strings can
often not be used in models unless they
are converted to factor variables
so
um the the mode function in there isn't
useful in and of itself but to know that
mode allows you to as blank
whatever one conversion you want to do
that's really really useful
um i mean i i always use double quotes i
didn't mean to use single um
i
trying to remember um
i don't think there's a difference
single verse double quotes in r i
believe there's no differences uh within
r
it's just that double quotes is the
standard
and we'll verify single and double codes
character constants used interchangeably
double quotes are preferred so
um
yeah generally speaking just always use
double um
but you can use either
okay
and then summary uh i guess i already
ran that before but summary is really
really great to look at the distribution
of the data and make sure everything's
accurate
okay let's minimize this
hide this
now quiz time cool
so
this is kind of what we were talking
about before i didn't have a good
example for you guys
um so i will see how you guys answer it
and then i'll walk you through
um these in regards to what they do
right so
which of the following is a valid
equation um
true percent divided by percent false
equals true
true
and mind you this is an or operator
right um so true or false and false not
equal to true is equal to true true or
false and false not equal to true is
equal to false um or a and a
so i'll let you guys try to answer and
then i'll walk you through these to
let you know what each one is basically
asking
so these are really just and or not
operators you're
likely not going to be using these in
the real world too much but it is
important to understand it from a
logical perspective
because you may end up doing this in
like a for statement
okay bbb
[Music]
okay
all right
yeah most people answered okay so what
is it saying
well this is essentially a remainder
operation it's mathematical notation so
you can't do it um so
true with the remainder of false like or
what would the remainder be if three
divided by false there wouldn't be one
uh so it doesn't make sense
this is saying uh we have to look at
this in a couple different ways right
and um
pull this up
okay
let's highlight the uh let's make this a
little bit smaller okay
so this operates as true or false right
so either one of those options
and false is not equal to true so this
is another operator this is another set
of operators i you see the parentheses
so they operate in a different space so
this is saying that this could be true
or false
and
this is saying that we need to verify
that false is not equal to true well
that's true right um false is not equal
to true
um so this this produces a true
statement
and then this is true or false so it
could be either
true or false
and true so it hits true and true so it
is equal to true
you know this one is saying um
essentially the opposite right so if
this had been a true and false well it
can't be true and false so it would be
false
false and true would produce a false but
because it is the same operation um
this is wrong because it's true
and then uh you know character strings
are
case sensitive so a is not equal to a
and
i think we're good there
all right let's clear that
cool
all right
so what would be the correct operator to
fit in the blank
for four blank three equals one so four
divided by three four times three
for a remainder three or none of the
above
all right
see a ton of c's
correct guys so yeah it's basically the
same what's the remainder once you
divide four by three um so that's
correct
well with the output of age
assigned to eighteen eight to sign to
age print age um so what would you guys
see if you ran that line of code
okay
looks like primarily a is in a couple of
b's
uh so what we see is we're saying that
we assigned age to 18
and then we also assigned 18 to 8 which
is the exact same thing
and then we printed age so this ended up
overwriting this first line but age is
still 18. so if we print age then it
should print 18. um so all this would
work because
this overwrites this preview statement
and we're just printing this
again you know generally speaking you
should never do these less assignment
operators but
you know in regards to r interpreting it
it can at least interpret it correctly
um
error messages quite common in our
you'll you'll see and get frustrated but
that's perfectly okay
you will basically never see n a's and
uh you know r isn't uh
like c or something like that so it
never goes into binary
okay
and you can go ahead and type this out
yourself if you wanted to but yeah once
you're assigning the variable age or 18
to the variable h and printing it you're
going to get the variable 18.
can an if statement
be used without an else block
all right you guys all answered that
quick too smart for your own good
uh yeah you so you don't necessarily
have to have an elf statement in there
that's pretty much all you need to know
it's uh i mean you're generally going to
because you generally won't create an if
statement if it doesn't exist um but
it is perfectly feasible and r will run
it
okay what would the output of num one
through five for val and num next break
print val b
output will be out uh error output will
be numbers three four five there's no
output infinite loop
take your time take it through
no rush
so you want to interpret each line of
this code
bye
all right what do we get here
all right i'll let a few more people
answer as well now we have five so far
let's see one two three four five six
seven
see if we can get two or three more
answers on here i think we have 13 in
here or 12.
so i guess that could be a 10. okay
okay
so
output would be c now why is that okay
well what we're doing is we create a
vector of numbers one two three four and
five
and it's saying for each value in number
we'll move to the next one and then we
break it
and then i print val
because this break is right here
it doesn't print anything
because we didn't ask it to print the
evaluation before the break
so all it does is essentially move right
to the break instead of nothing will end
up printing out
that make sense you guys
if you move the break then it would be
different you can move the break to
after this because you went to next
first it would start at one it would
move to two three four five
okay
so
you guys just learned a ton of
information right there's four types of
operators arithmetic relational logical
and assignment
so arithmetic are the typical um plus
minus multiplication etc
uh relational like and or logical true
false um assignment is uh
labeling variables
there's two types of conditional
statements in r
um if else nested if else um
there's the if elif else as well um
and that you can do definitely do nested
if else statements within r
there's three types of loops the for
loop the while loop which is limitations
in the repeat loop which will go on
until there's a break
if you wanted to run an r script you
could use that source function you can
use echo with it to see what the syntax
is
if you had a batch of scripts you wanted
to run you could use the r command batch
command
become these functions we went through
all of these
again you know you have access to these
slides so feel free
you could also
go ahead and use any of these with that
diamonds beta set so now that's loaded
you know you can look at the range of
some variable in there which would mean
you do diamonds dollar sign and the
variable name
um
there's no character strings in there so
the lower and upper won't really work
you know you could do unique of any
variable in there again it's diamonds
dollar sign the variable name um and you
can get all the unique values
so all these can be done if you wanted
to append you can append to that data
set you're good
sure asia
um
[Music]
okay
so i'll meet you real quick and then we
will
i'll answer any questions and then we
just have i think like seven slides
looking at vectors um and then
um i can let you guys go early and i'll
stay to answer any questions
hey um matt can you hear me i can
okay yeah perfect so what i'm trying to
do here is i'm looking at all these
functions and everything that is
providing and we do quite a bit of data
um you know mining and sorting them and
trying to understand how we can come up
with the best modeling for the work that
we do so out of all these functions that
you have if i want to run effect project
take this learning today and do this
quick project on the data that we
already have within the office so what
do you think are the most popular
functions that we can do with
um
yeah so in regards to um that the
so we have uh the view which you know
produces the data so you can kind of get
a look at it and you can skim through it
and make this full size
um so that's really nice right so just
kind of get an understanding you can
sort in here so it's a great little
feature and it's pretty fast for it
being an r you know you have 50 000 rows
can still skim through all this quick
the summary and structure are really
really important i use those all the
time
and then there are two others
that i didn't include
um
and i'll send a good link for each of
these for you guys in here
but
there's two right so this one here
is a correlation matrix it might feel
like you don't have to you know
use all these memorize all these
anything like that
so this first link uh correlation plot
looks at sets of relationships the
correlation between all variable types
with all the variable types and so you
can see here this is the positive one to
negative one correlation uh obviously
uh any variable is fully correlated with
itself but you can see like you know
miles per gallon is inversely correlated
with the number of cylinders right or
the numbers of these uh power
so this one's really really useful i
often use the numbers uh i use this
primarily to
handle something called
multicollinearity i think we'll get into
that later essentially
multicollinearity
looks at data and if you have two
predictor variables that are really
highly correlated then their actual
strength of impact on your outcome
variable will be reduced um so basically
if you had something like uh
dispersion with cylinders you can see
these colors are pretty similar right or
if we go to the numbers um 0.9
correlation between the two
i would only use one of those two in a
model um because their accuracy would be
reduced if i included both
the correlation plot uh really important
to look at this relationship between
predictors
and then scatter plot matrices are
really really nice so when we get into
visualization scatter plots are
fantastic guys
um and the reason we might do that is to
get an understanding of the data within
a variable so um yeah
like this you know you can see it's a
strong linear equation but if i look
at
scatter plot matrix um actually i should
do it in r
so if i go scatter plot matrix in r and
we'll go to like this one even though
it's a little bit smaller
we can see this one in the bottom corner
it looks like it has something called a
curve a linear function right yes linear
function is good but the curve linear
means that we have to do a data
transformation
yep yep so yeah i square the original
variable uh to make sure that it then
creates like a linear composite
um so those are like the primary things
i do in regards to the data
investigation phase
okay so one more question so we do on
this the correlation of scatterplots
everything is available in excel as well
so we do that
how how is it different in terms of
doing the exact same work in excel
though it is you know scalability is
always a big question versus doing it on
and you showed me one example where you
can look at the data pretty fast which
is very important for us as well
yeah so like you know with uh like if
you were in excel to do a scatter plot
you'd have to do it for every variable
with every other variable
but this scatter plot matrix it's
actually a function right so i can do
all i have to do is uh where is it um
matrix here we go so i could do pairs
and i could say okay i want you to look
at the relationships between these four
sets of variables
in this data set and so
that single line of code produces this
whole thing
so instead of you having to manually
create six of these
you automatically created all those with
one line of code
so yeah it makes it
okay okay
you answered all my questions man thank
you very much sure thank you
okay um let's see
how to accept input value from user in r
um rahul what do you mean
and while you're responding to that
you go back to the next function and
here
um
i i mean i could take guest meet or
something uh can you explain uh more in
detail what you mean i can't remember if
you have a mic though
and i mean if you mean in regards to
like a survey or something in that
regard um you know there's nothing
that's uh
there's no live stream in regards to r
well i'll i'll let you type for a sec um
and then i'll answer the niches so
uh manish uh you can see here the next
statement helps in skipping current
iteration of a loop so
you might want to and this is where like
nested
statements would end up working really
effectively um so if you got to a point
where if the value is equal to three
then next then you can skip and then you
could have another if statement that
works like that
uh kind of like break but it would skip
a you know specific value or specific
something that you're trying to do
and then your other question a grep yeah
so
that's why i sent those regex things um
wrap in our examples
let me see if there's
maybe vanderbilt's site
so yeah like uh
here's one example right so this here is
saying
um g sub is some another part of the
grip package and we're saying okay let's
do a substitute let's find any place we
see a dollar sign let's replace it with
a dot right
and there's plenty of other ones too so
you look at all these pattern matchings
you can do
you can do string splits
so there's a ton you can do with it
um and uh
it really depends on what string you
have what you're trying to do
i i mean i can share this link as well
because it looks like it's pretty good
in regards to the information there
um
[Music]
value parameter
give something else you mean towards
that
no i don't know interesting um
uh do you have a link or something that
you saw
i've never heard it used that's what i'm
asking
unless you mean these pieces here which
is just a function of filter function
okay
yeah
so yeah if you have something like that
then the easiest way is going ahead and
doing that help function
and then going in and seeing how it's
defined um because a lot of times
filters and parameters you don't
necessarily know how it's defined um
so you're saying the value filter okay
so we go down to value if false a vector
containing
let's go away uh if also vector
containing the
integer if it's an integer indices the
match is determined by graph is returned
and if true vector containing the
matching elements themselves are
returned um so that means that uh you
know do you want the actual numbers
themselves
and those actual elements for the row
that the elements are in
okay cool
um
all right
so i will go through this next set um
and then i'll post the poll
since we forgot to do that or i forgot
to do that during break i apologize um
which is just that one question survey
and then i'll stay on for any other
questions anything else you guys want to
do or explore
but
it'll let you guys get out of here early
if you want to
so the last piece we have again we're
not going through all of data structures
today we're just getting into vectors
which you guys basically know what the
heck they are already um
so
different data structures elements of
different data structures and acceptable
formats to import and export data so
we'll get into these other pieces um
next weekend but what we have here
essentially
there's vectors matrices arrays and data
frames and then i guess technically you
have list two they're not the same as
python list
so
vectors are one-dimensional arrays right
um the best way to think about it is a
single column um and so this one
labeled the vector a is concatenating
this set of seven numbers
or this set of three character strings
or this set of six logical operators um
and there you go right it says numeric
character and logical vectors uh so all
those are completely feasible within a
vector themselves uh they can only be a
single class
whereas like lists could be multi-class
you can also have one element vectors
again those are called scalars
but they're essentially synonymous it's
just a one by one matrix
just like a vector is a n by one
vector
the colon operator we've already gone
through quite a few times it just tries
to make things more efficient and easier
so this one
colon five is the exact same thing as c
c12345
seems arbitrary now but if you're trying
to put in you know a million operators
you don't want to do that by hand so
that's where this comes in much more
efficiently and that's where you know if
you needed to create a list or some sort
of vector
that's where that sequence could come in
handy as well so you could sequence like
one through
a million by uh 13 something like that
and then numeric vectors of positions
within brackets is used to refer to
various elements of a vector and so what
does that mean well let's say we create
this vector that concatenates the
letters a through f
vect with bracket one returns the first
element of the vector so if i ran if so
if you built this out right
and you concatenated a through f labeled
it back
vect one is going to return a it returns
the first item in the list like vector
would return b right
you can also
pull multiple things out so you could do
c 2 colon 4 and it would give you b c
and d you could do 2 comma 4 and it'll
give you b and d
so it's a way of using the essential
index function to access the vector
itself
um
the first one won't
it shouldn't produce anything because
it's concatenation
unless it's just a shortcut that exists
now
um this should just produce an error or
it won't okay
um
i always suggest using the concatenate
function because it can produce um
erroneous
in other cases it can produce some
erroneous things
this didn't used to run as a function
itself but it looks like it does now
so
uh we'll get into a raise that some more
i'm sorry next saturday
um because yeah there are just like some
nuance differences between a lot of this
stuff in our
you know something like python or java
has that much more explicitly defined
um in r
not always so and you'll end up seeing
things like there's a data dot table
there's a frame
and there's a couple of things in
regards to how these are done
where
they're basically i mean because
pretty much all the data you work with
is still
a flat file right
number of rows by columns and you're not
working multi-dimensional in that stage
but some of these like a data table
versus data frame can process things
faster
so there's some nuances that are just
involved in the playing around with the
data process
and that's why like us going through
this uh next weekend will make things
easier in regards to you knowing what
you need to do
so that
it runs as efficiently as possible
and yep okay so that's where we'll stop
for today um real quick before
you want to ask any questions let me go
ahead and run this poll real quick for
you guys um
might not let you pulling okay
so
let's
oops um let's open and we're going to
pull this from
my let's see what do i have that
downloads okay
so uh just one question um
please answer that just the next two or
three minutes
um
i will hide that so your answer is your
answers are anonymous anyways i don't
know who says what but uh just review
for me to know if i need to slow down
speed up if you guys are getting
everything
and um and then after you fill that out
um if you have any questions feel free
to stay
i have 30 minutes to answer any
questions you guys have
otherwise can let you go early and i
thank you for your time
and again you'll get that net promoter
score as soon as you exit out of there
the
one through six is a detractor um which
means that you hate this course and they
hate me
uh set up three is a passive which means
you're not satisfied and please let us
know we're doing better and then nine
and ten
our promoters so that's what i'm aiming
to be at
based on both the course material and
how i've taught
but please fill that out as feedback
from me
uh manish so the recordings are listed
um in r um i know that uh vishal could
uh go back through it again uh he went
through it um
yesterday evening but um can show you
exactly where to go to download those
oh uh the recordings i think take 24 to
48 hours to post i'm sorry
sure scott
and i can take it out from you if you
want to or you can just type it
thanks jay you too i appreciate it
yeah scott um so and if you want to say
uh i i can i can give michelle access uh
um to let you um to go back through kind
of what he went through yesterday
because i think we didn't have you here
yesterday yep
um so he could show you that in regards
to where you can download the slides the
lectures as well as the recordings for
this course so those recordings uh uh as
i was telling manish uh aren't posted
for i believe 24 to 48 hours um so
you'll be able to access that probably
on monday um if not today
uh but the rest uh he can walk you
through if you want to uh see where to
access everything on the course
thank you chef have a great day
uh yeah the slides are already on there
so you could go directly into r and on
the right hand side um i believe
sorry i just
lost access because my
my previous course expired
but what you should see
um
[Music]
so i won't be able to fully get in here
that's why i said he can walk you
through
um but
this data science with r if you go into
it and then on this right hand side um
there should be a button up here that'll
let you click and you can end up
downloading
uh yep
we made it through everything so if you
have questions or want to play around
i'm happy to stay on otherwise i hope
you have a great rest of your weekend
you too
uh uh it's not quite a data table um
it's uh i mean it's really just a vector
but um
uh
because the what you'll see is that
the instructor structures um vectors
matrices arrays data frames and list are
all
i don't know a cognitive component but
then there's uh different ways of
reading data which is right data that
table um
read that csv date of that frame so
there's a few different ways that the
data can be assessed and
in regards to the calculations that are
done that can have an impact on
performance
um
okay i'm gonna keep going in order let's
see individually we'll see the functions
practices but how will relate to real
world i'm still not able to link up
uh yeah manish i'm gonna keep uh going
through this try to bring in real world
examples and whatnot but i think once uh
and that's why i brought the diamonds
data set up today um you know it wasn't
required for me
to do but i kind of wanted you to see
what this looks like for a data
scientist so you may end up having
hundreds of variables and millions of
rows but essentially what you're doing
is you have this data structure and now
this is a clean data set right
everything's filled in everything's nice
there aren't those issues with like
integers and numeric or character
strings anything erroneous
so there's a nice like
data set to play around with look at the
structure um you know and i mean like
there's nothing that's stopping you from
saying
oh i want to build a linear model right
and
see if i can do this off the top of my
head so i want to build a linear model
and i want to predict the
price
that might make sense
based on the carrot
uh cut
color and clarity right
and that data set is diamond
so this should run i hope
okay
and then
um
the results here
what is the best way to look at results
um
so i ran that and i can see you know and
we'll get into all this but like so this
means these variables are significant um
these are their coefficients which means
like okay the carrot um contributes
almost nine thousand dollars when
building the model um and then cut you
know looks like it could be plus or
minus depending on the cut you know
color takes an inverse hit on l but is
positive for four through uh for four
and so all this and then you end up
seeing like okay so those four
items carrot cut color and clarity
predict price
with essentially 92 percent accuracy
so that's how all this will end up
relating you don't have to worry about
all this now i'm just trying to help get
you to understand r and kind of reading
the syntax and being able to leverage it
uh
but it's not necessary that
you combine everything in your head yet
but this is kind of the work that you'll
end up doing um so a lot of it's that
data exploration process and then you
also have the model building
uh thanks scott thanks for cool
okay so if we're looking at calling x
the concatenation of two five three nine
eleven six
and then we assign
count as zero
for evaluation x
okay so this is saying that we start at
count 0
for each value in x
if
the value
[Music]
when you divide by 2
has a remainder of 0
then we'll add 1 to the count
and
then we'll rerun it and then we'll end
up printing that if that makes sense
thank you raj
um manish what do you mean by something
from your site can be done
and then yeah i mean we'll get into you
know all this in regards to data
modeling and analytics um
this course
uh which questions usher
why are you responding that yeah manish
so like uh we went through this today
we're going to get into apply functions
and deployer which are a lot of the data
cleaning
and then you know unit 4 is a lot of
visualization so like heat maps really
cool right
box plots word clouds blah blah blah
and then we start getting into the
actual statistics right so looking at
distribution types looking at distance
measures
um
and then we start getting into
hypothesis testing itself so
um
a b testing t-test z-test and uh
chi-squared getting into all those as
well as anovas which are comparing
multiple group differences and then we
actually get into the model building
like regression models least square
nonlinear regressions classifications
decision trees so this is all sequential
um we'll all
everything builds on each other so
that's why you're just learning the r
framework right now and and then
everything will build on that
so yeah we'll do the data modeling but
we want to make sure that you understand
the data structures first
and uh and how to visualize things
because it's part of the exploratory
data process data cleaning because all
that's done before the modeling and then
we'll actually get into hypothesis
testing which is the statistics uh which
is that cognitive framework and then the
actual data science modeling
yeah so if we go ahead and run this
right
so what it's doing is going through and
says okay so
if two is divisible by two equals zero
uh we'll move the count forward one um
so it should be two plus three right or
two plus one is three
does that make sense
the statement essentially ends up
stopping um because the first one uh it
doesn't leave a remainder of the
remainder zero so then we just say okay
the that number was one two plus one
equals three and print three um if it
had been
because what how this should work um if
it's five first
then i totally guess it'd be
nine
oops
two
five divided by two then the remainder
of one
if i divide by two equals two
what is that saying
then so this would run five first
five visible to zero then
why does it print something no it should
run loop through then three then eight
eight by two
uh the zero's not divided it's um
it's here where that count is zero plus
one
oh i see what it's doing okay so i think
the outcome will only be two or three
um because yeah
that counts
yeah what about you to zero
count what a zero
[Music]
so what is it printing then
i'm intrigued too um
because it's reassigning this but we
start at count equals zero
and then we say for value and x so we'd
start at four
if four
divided by two as a remainder of zero
then we would add count which would be
zero plus one which would be one
so then we would reiterate through
now that counts 1
and we would say
for value in 3 so for 3 if 3 divided by
2 is a 0 it's
not then it shouldn't do anything
okay so that makes sense so what it's
doing is uh um four eight and six
um it loops through all these right
um
because there's no stop point
and so it loops through this whole
string
and this is saying if it has a remainder
of zero then we'll add it to the count
and so
the ones that will have remainder zero
are the even numbers so it's counting
four eight and six
and that's why
yeah
two
yep does that make sense
so the essential summary of this is that
yep it's basically just an account of
the evens
so like this should just do a count of
the odds um so
if i'm not wrong this should be three as
well or we can add another one it should
be four
yep
uh so yeah so essentially it's saying um
all we're doing is counting um
the number of
even numbers so as long as uh it doesn't
have a remainder then we'll add it to
the count and start the new count number
over
so like when you get to six when it's
iterating through so it's just for six
is six
uh divided by two doesn't have a
remainder of zero um then we'd add that
to the count and it looks like we would
have already have a count of four and
eight also having that so it would be
two plus one equals three
yep
sure
yeah so i mean sometimes you have to
read through this and try to figure it
out um because yeah
it took me a second to realize that the
count was actually of the built-in
function count
okay great
anybody else have any questions
looks like a few people left
thanks have a great week
sure scott
um okay
um can you hear me yep i can alright
excellent um hey uh
had a couple questions for you um i
actually figured out the
the issue where i could repoint my
library so that was good awesome um
i had a question on actually a little
bit so you said you've been doing data
science for 10 years uh yeah for way too
long
i mean it wasn't called data science
back then
sure
so i'm actually approaching this from
i'm taking this class primarily um i'm
planning on being a i'm a platform admin
okay i do have some programming
background i was curious if you if you
knew of any
um
anything that might be
i wanna i definitely wanna do this
courses with a fantastic course for me
but i'm also interested in like our
server administration do you know if
anything out there like that
um i haven't but
i got an idea um
i'm mentor on springboard one of the
cool things they have built in
is a search function of course is all
over the internet
okay
so let's see
our server
web hatch
let's see i know shiny i'm just
wondering if it only does shiny um
is shiny
can you describe china i'm not quite
sure i understand what that actually
provides
yeah um it's uh basically interactive um
like tableau
yeah um the basically um so yeah that uh
you could live approach and people can
use drag and drop and sliders to handle
anything okay it's like data
visualization yep
okay okay um but yeah if you're
interested in our server
our stadium might have i'm trying to
remember if they do or not um they might
have
training on it
i couldn't find anything there i i
actually asked them and they sent me a
pdf and said here you go
i thought okay
that's uh
maybe there's just not much to it um
have you ever used um
revolution r or i know microsoft bought
them now
yeah yeah that was after my
last course um i haven't i mean i
followed them um with what they've done
but i haven't used it so okay um i mean
i was looking uh a show on the class
yesterday um
i forgot um
i don't want to blog
that's actually our server um
yeah they actually have interesting
microsoft's really trying to take over
the space oh yeah microsoft
revolution and they're
it's quite interesting because now
they're running linux servers
yeah so yeah if you can see this yeah
they have all of this built in for the
diving into the data analysis um and uh
so there's some interesting things in
here like since someone was asking about
pivot tables earlier there's the cross
tabs right there um built in so
this also has a ton of stuff as well but
i haven't had time to actually use it to
see how good it is
okay
all right well if you if you come across
anything i'd appreciate um
yeah i'll leave uh
um i guess i didn't
write your background down yet um
so what's uh
let's see what did i do before um
so have you worked with uh big data data
science space at all well i've been i've
been a
i would my background is the etl uh i
was an etl developer for years but i'm
now more of a platform architect and
admin so i've done sas for years um
informatica
bi tools like hyperion and stuff like
that
so i've been in that realm but i haven't
really gotten into this is kind of the
first foray into
um
big data as far as i haven't really had
a chance to mess around with hadoop yet
you know some of the newer technologies
sure
yeah and i mean um you know it it also
depends on
your
organization its needs and what not um
there's uh um i'm showing people
yesterday as well
so
yeah depend on how large the data is you
can uh install
you know our server but uh sometimes
that does have issues
yep yeah we we we've actually got
installations of our server installed
it's more of a
it's a proof of concept that's kind of
going into a production
area so we're going through that
we're going through that process
so that's something where it'll probably
be turned over to my team to manage
okay um yeah i mean like you know uh so
yeah i've been with organizations that
have had our server we sometimes were
often implemented um
apache spark
or h2o the nice things about both of
these is their big data processing the
nicer thing about both these is
uh
oh it's not going to show it on here
interesting h2o runs on top of hadoop so
um yep you can uh i think you put on aws
too but yeah it basically runs on hadoop
but the nice thing is that um you know
spark can run java in scala python or r
right um and then h2o also our python
scholar java as well as json
so um you know these are nicer because
they do handle big data processing in a
duplex fashion unlike our server uh and
you still get to use all of our syntax
right right so that's an option as well
and then there are you know courses on
spark and h2o
yep okay
all right and as far as so as far as the
um i wasn't able to attend last week
um you said that would be posted later
uh yeah um yeah
they
something i read um in regards to our
documentation said that the videos were
only posted 24 to 48 hours um after that
you're done uh but then all the slides
are already on there
where do i where would i find the slides
i would that be in the batches or
somewhere else um
so the batch themselves is where you
download the videos if you went into the
uh um i was saying that i
need to re-ask for
live access
but for the the r course um
once you like click on through here and
it should be on the right hand side
there should be um an icon with like
three lines and in there there should be
a download that leads to a zip file that
has all of the powerpoint punchlines
okay uh hold on just second if you think
that's right if i recall
let's see my uh
yeah basically you should get this right
side uh something should kind of pop out
and then there should be an option to
download a zip file
okay i might i might have to ask uh
somebody with simply learn because i
don't see that on mine but
that doesn't mean it's not
and and i don't know if our host is here
um he works uh uh um
directly in regards to the management of
uh
loading and making sure everything's
operating on the website so um and that
he's the one recording this as well so
um he could also provide access there if
um
you can't find it
all right hey appreciate it thank you
thanks scott have a great day
hey now uh yeah um the they should be
posted on the bat setting um
that our host was showing um yesterday
and uh but it'll take 24 to 48 hours for
it to be um posted and uploaded so um it
probably won't be available today but um
if you go on tomorrow you should be able
to get access and watch that
sure
thanks you too